OF JULY THIRD HEARING OF THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE FIRST WHATEVER ONE PLEASE
SILENCE THEIR CELL PHONES SECOND
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON MONDAY
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO UPDATES.
FIRST OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
FOR SB FIVE TWENTY THREE WAS
UPDATED THIS MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE PROVIDED WITH THE
UPDATED AND NOW OFFICE YESTERDAY
MORNING.
AND COPIES OF THE UPDATED
ANALYSIS ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
BACK OF THE ROOM.
SECOND THERE'S AN UPDATE ON THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
FOR SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT WIENER.
COPIES OF THE UPDATED LANGUAGE
WERE EMAIL TO COMMITTEE MEMBER
STAFF AND POSTED ONLINE
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON AND COPIES
OF THE LANGUAGE.
IS AVAILABLE ARE AVAILABLE AT
THE BACK OF THE ROOM
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION -- AS THE OTHER ONE
REAL GOT IT IS LOTS GOING ON
FINALLY GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
BILLS ON WHICH WE ARE EXPECTING
SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSION TODAY WE
WILL NEED TO ADHERE STRICTLY TO
THE COMMITTEES LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY.
AS A REMINDER TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO THREE WITNESSES PER
SIDE IN TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
ASKED TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL -- I
SEE THAT WE ARE.
WAY SHORT OF A QUORUM BUT WE DO
HAVE. TWO MEMBERS YOUR SOUL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE -- AND
WITH THAT CENTER LEYVA IF YOU
LIKE TO START WITH WHAT'S THE
FIFTY SEVENTY ONE SB SEVENTY ONE
ITEM NUMBER TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL I
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT.
I AM HERE TODAY AS A PROUD
AUTHOR OF SB SEVENTY ONE WHICH
WOULD PROHIBIT CANDIDATES OR
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM USING
CAMPAIGN FUNDS OR LEGAL DEFENSE
FUNDS. TO PAY FOR OR REIMBURSED
FOR A PENALTY JUDGMENT OR
SETTLEMENT RELATED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL ABUSE OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS.
THIS BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED
TO ALLOW CANDIDATES AND ELECTED
OFFICERS TO USE CAMPAIGN AND
LEGAL DEFENSE FUNDS UNTIL THEY
ARE FOUND LIABLE.
ONCE FOUND LIABLE FOR SUCH
VIOLATIONS SB SEVENTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
CANDIDATES TO REIMBURSE ALL
FUNDS USED TO PAY FOR LEGAL
EXPENSES.
AND FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CLAIM COLLEAGUES AS WE ALL KNOW
POLITICAL DONATIONS ARE MADE TO
A CANDIDATE'S EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
CAN ITS EFFORTS TO REPRESENT
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
NOT TO BE USED AS A SLUSH FUND
FOR BAD BEHAVIOR.
SB SEVENTY ONE HELPS TO RESTORE
INTEGRITY BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS HARASSERS TO DEPEND
ON DONATED FUNDS TO DEFEND THEIR
UNLAWFUL ACTIONS WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND FOR
FOLKS AS YOU ENTER THE HEARING
ROOM PLEASE KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. TO A MINIMUM WE
ARE CURRENTLY CONDUCTING THE
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS HAD ON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- WILL MAKE SURE THAT --
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND AND
AND A VOTE ON THE BILL VERY GOOD
THANK YOU AND I AND I WILL HAVE
AN AYE RECOMMENDATION AT THAT
TIME THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED
HAVE A GOOD REST TODAY THE
CENTER.
SO NOW WE ARE JUST WAITING FOR
AUTHORS -- SO IF IF YOU OR YOUR
STAFF IS ARE WATCHING ON TV COME
ON DOWN COME ON UP [inaudible]
TO A WHERE WE'D ROOM
[inaudible]
FOR FOR FOR THANK YOU
.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
AND ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN THEN WE
CAN -- IF THERE'S A MOTION
SECOND ON A NUMBER TO SB SEVENTY
ONE WE GET STARTED ON THAT.
BERMAN -- HERE BERMAN HERE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE CALDERON CALDERON
HERE LOW.
MAYES.
MAYES HERE MULLIN.
WEBER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM BEFORE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THE COMMITTEE
HEARD FROM CENTER LEYVA ON SB
SEVENTY ONE I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT -- IS OUR MOTION ON THE
BILL.
HAVE A MOTION.
I'LL MAKE THE SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I'D GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER I YEAH.
GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
I SEE CENTER MORE LOG HERE WITH
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX SB THREE FIFTY NINE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR.
ON THE LINE
.
LONG WAIT IN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A SECOND.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
I RECENTLY OBSERVED THE PURSUIT
OF A REFERENDUM IN ONE OF MY
CITIES WHERE A CLEVER BURDEN WAS
IMPOSED.
I FOUND IT TO BE ONEROUS AND
OBSTRUCTIVE TO THE DEMOCRATIC
FREEDOMS WE SHOULD ENJOY IN THIS
STATE.
WHEN A GROUP OF CITIZENS OPPOSE
THE DECISION OF ITS CITY COUNCIL
IF FILE TO COLLECT SIGNATURES?
TO PUT A RESPONSE ON ITS BALLOT
THE CITY COUNCIL.
AUTHORIZED THE SIGNATURE
GATHERING WITH ONE PROVISO
ATTACH THE INFIRM ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT. TO THE PETITION.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
WAS SOMEONE THOUSAND PAGES AND
CONSEQUENTLY VERY EXPENSIVE TO
REPRODUCE.
THERE'S EXHIBIT A THIS IS WHAT
THE PETITION GATHERERS HAD TO
CARRY AROUND.
THE TO GET SAYS SIGNATURES FOR
THE BALLOT MEASURE THIS THIS
ENTERPRISES CITIZENS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND IT SHOULD BE AVOIDED.
A SUMMARY OF THE E. I. R. SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN ADEQUATE AND
ALWAYS WHO'S GONNA WHO'S GONNA
TODAY AND READ THE WHOLE E. I.
R. BEFORE THEY SIGN A PETITION
LET ALONE.
MAYBE THEY COULD JUST GO TO A
WEBSITE AND LOOK AT THE
PERTINENCE.
SB THREE FIFTY NINE TRIES TO
FIND A COMPROMISE BETWEEN AND A
MASK ON AND I'M A MASSIVE
BOATING KERR.
DOCUMENT AND NO PROJECT DETAILS
AT ALL SURELY A TEN POUND
DOCUMENT IS OVER KILL IN MORE
WAYS THAN.
ONE WASTE THE PAPER.
THE PRINTING TOOK A NUMBER OF
CIRCULATION DAYS AWAY FROM THE
PETITIONERS.
SO ATTACHING SPECIFIED
DECORATIONS TO REFERENDUM
PROTECTION SHOULD BE A REASON
WHY POSITION AND NOT A
CUMBERSOME OBSTACLE TO THE
EXERCISE OF PARTICIPATORY
GOVERNMENT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT.
THANK YOU CENTER -- ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SOME SEVERE A FICKLE AT A
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE ARE
WE CURRENTLY ADOPTING THE
POSITION SUPPORT OF AMENDED
RECENTLY SEND ARMAMENTS A CENTER
MORE LAX OFFICE.
AND WE THINK DOCTOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND TAKING THE AND
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ALREADY
TAKEN AND WE WILL.
WE HOPE TO RESOLVE ANY --
CHALLENGES GOING FORWARD AND BUT
FOR NOW WE CANNOT SUPPORT UNTIL
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL CALL THAT IT'S
WIENER -- ANY OTHER TWEENER THIS
OR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANYONE
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES.
LET YOUR BILL SO CLEAR THAT
THERE'S THERE'S NOTHING TO
DISCUSS -- I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORD LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT ARE
THE SUBJECT OF REFERENDA CAN
OFTEN BE LENGTHY DUE TO THE
REQUIRED INCLUSION OF EXHIBITS
THAT ARE PART OF THE ORDINANCE.
THIS BILL SETS UP A REASONABLE
ALL ALTERNATIVE FOR PROPONENTS
TO USE WHEN PURSUING A
REFERENDUM OF A LENGTHY CITY
ORDINANCE -- I'LL BE VOTING AYE
ON THIS BILL AND RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON CALDERON
AYE LOW.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
WEBER I'VE WEBER ON THAT BILLS
OUT ONLY WITH WITH FIVE VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THINK THE SENDER.
AND I SEE CENTER AMBERG -- AS
JOINED US WITH ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB SIX NINETY SIX CHAIR ON BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- HIM BEFORE YOU SB.
SIX NINE SIX PURPOSE IS TO
PREVENT MISLEADING VOTER
REGISTRATION.
THE IMPETUS OF THIS BILLS TO
REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION AND TO
EFFECTUATE VOTER INTENT
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
THE SECOND LARGEST GROUP OF
VOTERS IN INDIVIDUALS ARE
REGISTERED AS NO PARTY
PREFERENCE.
THIS GROUP IS MORE COMMONLY
REFERRED TO IS INDEPENDENCE.
YOU SEE THAT AND POLLING DATA
YOU SEE THAT.
AS REPORTED IN VARIOUS
PUBLICATIONS THIS GROUP IS
TWENTY EIGHT POINT 6% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTING ELECTORATE.
IS THE FASTEST GROWING SET OF
ALL VOTERS IN FACT I THINK IT'S
THE SECOND LARGEST IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW.
NOR REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION
ESPECIALLY AMONGST VOTERS.
WHO WISH TO NOT REGISTER WITH
ANY PARTY AND STAY INDEPENDENT
THE POLITICAL PARTIES?
SB SIX NINE SIX WILL PROHIBIT
THE NAME OF A POLITICAL PARTY
FROM INCLUDING THE WORD
INDEPENDENT.
DECLINE TO STATE OR NO PARTY
PREFERENCE OR ANY VARIATION OF
THOSE WORDS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW IT IS
PROHIBITED FOR THE NAME OF A NEW
PARTY TO BE SIMILAR TO AN
EXISTING PARTY TO AVOID
MISLEADING VOTERS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU COULDN'T
FORMA PARTY THEY CALLED THE
DEMOCRATS OR THE REPUBLICANS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PROTECTION
DOES NOT EXTEND INDEPENDENT
VOTERS.
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF WYOMING
BANDS THE WORD INDEPENDENT IN
THE NAME OF ANY NEW POLITICAL
PARTY.
TODAY THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT
PARTY IS OVER A HALF MILLION
REGISTERED MEMBERS MORE THAN ALL
OF CALIFORNIANS OTHER MINOR
PARTIES COMBINE.
THE REASON FOR THIS LARGE AMOUNT
OF REGISTERED.
AMERICAN PEN PARTY MEMBERS IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD.
LIST POSSIBLE PARTIES IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
SO AS A RESULT THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY IS THE FIRST
CHOICE.
THAT FOLKSY -- AT THE ENVY FOR
EXAMPLE.
A POLL CONDUCTED BY THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES FOUND THAT FEWER
THAN 4%.
A REGISTERED AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT VOTER PARTY VOTERS.
COULD CORRECTLY IDENTIFY THEIR
OWN REGISTRATION IS A MEMBER OF
A PARTICULAR PARTY THE AMERICAN.
INDEPENDENT PARTY THE SAME POLL
NOTED THAT MORE THAN 50%.
A REGISTERED AMERICAN IN PENN
PARTY MEMBERS WANT TO LEAVE THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
ONCE THERE READ EXCERPTS OF
THEIR PARTY'S PLATFORM.
EVEN THE OF FORMER CHAIRMAN OF
THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
MARK SEIDENBERG.
ACKNOWLEDGES VOTER CONFUSION BY
SAYING QUOTE THIS IS IN THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES QUOTE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WHEN THEY FILL OUT A FORM.
END QUOTE MR SEIDENBERG WENT ON
TO SAY THAT ONE REASON THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
DOES NOT WANT TO CHANGE ITS NAME
IS THAT THE PARTY WOULD BE
FORCED TO QUOTE GET NEW VOTERS
AND THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
END QUOTE.
UNLIKE REGISTERED VOTERS AS NO
PARTY PREFERENCE THOSE ARE TRUE
INDEPENDENCE.
WHO ARE REGISTERED WITH THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY -- IF
YOU'RE REGISTER WITH AMERICAN
PEN BAR YOU CAN'T CAST YOUR VOTE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
UNLESS PARTICULAR IMPORTANT AS
IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL PRIME IS COMING UP
NEXT MARCH -- THIS VOTER
CONFUSION HAS REAL WORLD
CONSEQUENCES IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT A SPEAR
COURT JUDGE.
ORDERED ALEXIAN OFFICIALS TO
CHANGE AN INDIVIDUAL VOTERS
REGISTRATION.
TO NO PARTY PREFERENCE SO THAT
HER BALLOTS COULD BE COUNTED IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY.
AFTER SHE PETITIONS SAYING THAT
SHE HAD MISTAKENLY REGISTER WITH
THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
A CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE -- NOT
AT THE SUIT TO EXERCISE THEIR
FRANCHISE WITH ME IS MISTER PAUL
MITCHELL -- SACRAMENTO BASED
ELECTIONS EXPERT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
PLEASE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I FIRST OFF I WANT TO
NOTE THAT THERE IS EXCELLENT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT GOES
THROUGH A LOT OF THESE DETAILS
AND GIVES THE HISTORY -- I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW ABOUT MY
PERSONAL HERE'S HISTORY WITH
THIS AS SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKED IN
ELECTIONS FOR THE LAST. THIRTY
YEARS.
I THE HISTORY MOSTLY HAS BEEN
ANECDOTAL.
OF FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
CAMPAIGNS KNEW THAT WHEN THEY
SAW SOMEBODY WHEN THE PRECINCT
WALKING OR TALK TO SOMEBODY ON
THE PHONE WHO WAS AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT.
THAT THEY WERE VOTER PROBABLY
WANTED TO REGISTER INDEPENDENT.
AND AS WE BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP
THE FEEDBACK WE ALWAYS RECEIVED
WAS THE YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST
ANECDOTES.
AND SO I WORKED WITH THE LA
TIMES -- WITH DEMOCRATIC
POLLSTER BEEN TOLD CHEN AND
REPUBLICAN POLLSTERS SMITH
JOHNSON RESEARCH TO ACTUALLY DO
THE FIRST STUDY OF THESE VOTERS.
AND WE CONTACTED.
AS MANY AS VOTERS AS WE COULD
FROM THAT POLITICAL PARTY TO TRY
TO IDENTIFY NOT JUST POLICY
STANCES BUT WHETHER THEY COULD
IDENTIFY THEIR POLITICAL PARTY
AND AND IF THEY FELT THAT THEY
WERE BEING MISINFORMED.
AND AS THE ANALYSIS SITES AND AS
WAS NOTED BY THE SENATOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE.
THAT WERE CONTACTED DID NOT KNOW
THAT THEIR REGISTERED WITH THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
IN FACT IN OUR MOST RECENT --
OPENED.
UP IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A PART
OF CALIFORNIA WEEKLY.
ARE A CAPITAL WEEKLY -- WE'VE
BEEN DOING SOME POLLING AND AS
OF THIS MORNING.
WE CONTINUE TO DO POLLING I'M
GONNA READ YOU RESPONSES FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE NAMING THEIR
POLITICAL PARTY IN A PULL THIS
MORNING.
THESE ARE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT
PARTY VOTERS AND THE RESPONSES
READ INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT NON INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT. NINE
MOSTLY INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT NO PARTY AFFILIATION
INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT YOU HAVE
TO GO DOWN ABOUT A HUNDRED
RESPONSES FROM PEOPLE.
WHO ARE REGISTERED AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT WHO WHEN POLLED AND
ASKED WHAT IS YOUR POLITICAL
PARTY?
CAN PROPERLY IDENTIFY THAT THE
REGISTERED AMERICAN INDEPENDENT.
I SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
CONTINUED EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
SHOWN A LIGHT ON IT WITH THE LA
TIMES.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS
CONTINUED I YOU KNOW EVEN AS
THEIR OF AN ACTIVE CAMPAIGNS AND
EFFORTS TO TRY TO INFORM VOTERS --
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT AT THIS
POINT I BELIEVE TALKING WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AND
WITH LEGISLATORS.
THERE'S REALLY NO OTHER
APPROPRIATE REMEDY TO TRY TO
RESOLVE THIS.
IT DOES BRING UP IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT.
THE ISSUE OF IS THERE A
COMPELLING STATE INTEREST AND MY
ARGUMENT IS THAT VOTER INTENT IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
YOU AS A COMMITTEE OR THE STATE
AND MINISTERING ELECTIONS CAN.
HOLD ON TO IS VOTER INTENT AND
THERE'S CLEAR VOTER INTENT HERE
FOR PEOPLE TO REGISTER AN
AFFILIATE WITHOUT BEING A PART
OF A POLITICAL PARTY BEING
INDEPENDENT OR NO PARTY
PREFERENCE.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS FREEDOM OF
ASSOCIATION.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT FREEDOM
OF ASSOCIATION DOESN'T COUNT IF
YOU'RE BEING MISLED OR TRACTOR
UNAWARE OF WHAT YOUR ASSOCIATING
WITH.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF EVIDENCE
AND CONTINUE TO BUILD EVIDENCE
TO SHOW THAT PEOPLE REGISTERED
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT.
ARE NOT INTENDING TO BE A PART
OF THIS POLITICAL PARTY I AM BE
AFFILIATED WITH IT -- THEY ARE
CHOOSING TO BE NO PARTY
PREFERENCE AND I ALSO WANT TO BE
DOWN ONE RUMOR.
THAT IS THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT JUST HAPPENS TO LOW
INFORMATION VOTERS.
PEOPLE WHO JUST DON'T GET IT
ACCIDENTALLY GET TRICKED INTO
THIS -- THERE ARE TWO FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THE OF INCUMBENT
STATE LEGISLATORS WHO BEEN
REGISTER AMERICAN INDEPENDENT.
THERE IS STAFF MEMBER THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AND
THERE IS A MEMBER OF THIS
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
THAT HAVE BEEN REGISTERED
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT INCORRECTLY.
SOME VERY VERY VERY ENGAGED AND
IN A COUPLE CASES ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO DID NOT KNOW THAT
THEY HAD INADVERTENTLY
REGISTERED WITH A POLITICAL
PARTY WITH VERY STRIDENT
POLITICAL STANCES.
AND IN FACT THEY THOUGHT THEY
REGISTERED INDEPENDENT.
AND AS WE GO TOWARDS THE PRIMARY
WE START TO SEE WHERE THIS
REALLY HAS AN ACT AN ACUTE HARM.
IF SOMEBODY IS AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT AND ALL THEIR IF
THEY BELIEVE THEY'RE INDEPENDENT.
AND THEY'RE READING IN THE
PAPERS AND SEEING ON THE NEWS
THAT THEY CAN VOTE AND THE OPEN
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES.
THEY WOULD NOT BE.
PLANNING ON DOING OTHER THING
THAT JUST GETTING THEIR BALLOT
AND SEEING THE OPPORTUNITY VOTE
FOR THOSE PRIMARY CANDIDATES BUT
IN FACT THEY CAN'T.
AND AS WAS NOTED -- THERE WAS
ONE INSTANCE WHERE A JUDGE
INTERVENE -- SO.
IT IS VERY SERVICES UNIT ISSUE
AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT IS
NOTICES IN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO GO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PARKS ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS.
WE'RE SORRY THAT WE'RE TALKING
WITH OUR LETTER WE ONLY MET JUST
THIS LAST FRIDAY THOUGH BUT WE
VOTED IN SUPPORT OF THIS THANK
YOU.
VERY MUCH.
TIFFANY MARKHAM BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY STATES OFFICE WE ARE
IN SUPPORT.
ADDRESS FOR LACK OF A LETTER AT
THIS POINT.
WHEN IS IT IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE SECOND.
THE MEDICAL ROOM LOWERED.
OKAY.
REMOVAL AS SOON AS WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA WRAP UP WITH SUPPORT NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE OPPOSITION --
IF ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
AND THE FOR FREE IF IT'S EASIER.
TO THAT MICROPHONE OR YOU CAN
COME TO THE DESK YOUR LIFE
[inaudible]
CHAIRMAN BERMAN.
I MARKHAM ROBINSON.
CHAIRMAN OF THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY. TO OPPOSE.
SB.
SIX NINETY SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG.
DESIGNATED ELECTIONS POLITICAL
PARTIES.
THIS BILL PROPOSES.
THE GRAVE LOSS TO OUR PARTY.
OF OUR WELL ESTABLISHED NAME.
THE MORE WERE ABOUT QUALIFIED
STATUS.
SHOULD REPLACEMENT.
NOT BE FOUND APPROPRIATE
[inaudible]
THIS TAKING.
BUT THEN THE BILL BILL OF
ATTAINDER.
INDEED OUR PARTY ALONE.
VIOLATES OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH
[inaudible]
AND ASSOCIATION.
IN PROCESS OF LAW.
AN EQUAL PROTECTION OF THE LAW.
IN WOULD SUBJECT.
THE TAXPAYERS OF THIS STATE. TO
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LIABILITY.
OUR PARTY NAME.
ADOPTED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN IS NO
RECENT INVENTION SO WHY NOW THIS
HAZARD TO IT.
EXCEPT KERN POLITICAL INTERESTS.
BUT THE OPPOSITION POLITICAL
PARTIES.
IN CAMPAIGNS [inaudible]
REMARKABLY.
SB SIX NINETY SIX SAYS.
VOTER EDUCATION IS INEFFECTIVE.
IN REMAINING THIS VOTER
CONFUSION.
GET NO PROOF.
THIS ALLEGE CONFUSION CAUSED BY
INDEPENDENT BY OWNED BY.
OFFICIALS STUDY EXISTS.
NOR HAS ANY ADEQUATE ARE
COMPETENT [inaudible]
EFFORT.
EDUCATE VOTERS ON THE NATURE
PARTY'S.
PARTY NAMES. FOR POSITIONS BEEN
CONDUCTED.
ESPECIAL SORT.
GREAT EFFORTS.
WERE MADE OVER THE YEARS TO
REDUCE OUR PARTY THE NUMBERS.
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH WAS A
CONSPIRACY.
BY THE NIXON ADMINISTRATION USE
A GANG OF **** ACTUAL NEXT. TO
INTIMIDATE REGISTRANTS INTO
CHANGING PARTIES.
LATELY A HOSTILE LA TIMES.
EVIDENTLY SERVICE IS THE VOTER
EDUCATION ARM AND THE STATE.
IN RESEARCH FACILITY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS.
IN A SACRAMENTO BASED CONSULTING
FIRM.
HAVE TRIED TO SABOTAGE -- SEARCH
EFFORTS HAVE ONLY BECAUSE OUR
ROLES AS WELL.
SB.
SIX NINETY SIX YES THE DESPERATE
EFFORT. TO ACCOMPLISH BY THE
FORCE OF AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW
WHAT PERSUASION COULD NOT.
AFTER THE TONE OF THE SUPPORT
ELEMENT IS SAY I I WILL PASS.
LIMIT AND I LOVE THAT FOR THIS
HEARING FOR THIS I CHEN I'M AS
WELL AND THE GONNA GET STRICTLY
BACK TO TWO MINUTES PER PERSON.
AFTER THE SIGN.
FOR MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I AM MARK SEIDENBERG VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY.
ALSO HERE TO OPPOSE SB.
SIX NINETY SIX AS A TRADITIONAL
JEW I AM HERE.
LEAD THE CLAIM OF HISTORY AND
TRADITION.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE
A. B. MADE A FREE CHOICE OF ITS
NAME.
GUIDED BY A WISE WOMAN.
THIS CHOICE WAS NOT [inaudible]
ARBITRARY OR OPTIMISTS.
NOT FAR FROM IT.
IN. NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN FIFTY
TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE GUIDED BY
THE SELF.
PERCEPTION OF THOSE SUPPORTING
[inaudible]
OUR MOTION [inaudible]
IN.
THANKS TO OUR MOVEMENT YEAH OUR
SELECTION.
HE LEANS HERE THE WIFE OF OUR
FOUNDER WILLIAMS HERE.
QUIZ EVERY SUPPORTER SHE COULD
FIND AND ASKED.
HOW THEY WOULD CHARACTERIZE
THEIR POLITICAL POSITION?
THE TYPICAL ANSWER [inaudible]
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT.
SO WE DROPPED THE THE NAME.
AMERICAN THE PEN THE PARTY
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS OUR OFFICIAL
NAME ACCORDING TO THE LECTURE
CODE SECTION.
SEVEN FIVE ZERO ZERO NOT ONLY DO
WE HAVE A NAME ASSOCIATED WITH
OUR PARTY.
BUT WE HAVE A TRADE MARK OF A
BLUE LEGAL.
BEARING OUR PARTY NAME ON A
SCROLL.
AND A LEGEND NO NORTH NORTH
SOUTH LOW HE'S.
NO WEST ONE GREAT NATION.
HEAVEN BLESSED.
ADOPTED AUGUST.
NINETEEN SEVENTY AS OUR PARTY
FLAG.
ASSERTING OUR DEVOTION TO THE
UNION.
AS WELL AS TO OUR THE MOTION TO
INDEPENDENCE.
AT EVERY LEVEL.
THE A. I. P. FERVENTLY SUPPORTS
THE INDEPENDENCE OF STATES
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND OUR NATION'S IN
THE PENDANTS FROM ALL FORMS
SOVEREIGNS.
WE SUPPORT THE EQUAL FAVOR.
THE A INDEPENDENCE OF ALL
PERSONS WITHIN THE BOUNDS.
OF THE LAWS OF LIMITED
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THROUGH AMERICAN INDEPENDENCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S ONE
ASPECT.
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR FOR WHERE
I COULD ACTUALLY SAY THIS SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME I'LL
TRY TO STICK TO TWO MINUTES.
FIRST OFF I WANT TO SAY -- I
WANT TO BE HERE BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP IS GREAT AS PRESIDENT THAT
WE PASSAGE GEORGE WASHINGTON.
I DON'T TAKE NO BONES ABOUT THAT
HE IS THE BEST AND MY NAME IS
VINCE IN MAY.
CHAIRMAN BERMAN ARE I'M WITH
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY HERE
TO POSE BILLS.
SIX NINE SIX AS MARINE FORMER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IT IS MY
PRIVATE PRACTICE TO FOLLOW RULES
AND REGULATIONS.
BUT THE RULES PROPOSED BY SB SIX
NINE SIX FRANKLY MAKES YOU WANT
TO MUTINY.
THIS BILL RE ECTS SUPPORTERS
PARTISAN MOTIVES.
IT SINGLES OUT FOR MANY AMOUNTS
TO POLITICAL CAPITAL PUNISHMENT
BUT BUT WHY.
WHY ARE PARTY NOMINATION
NOMINATED DONALD TRUMP?
AND WE ARE IN AT JUST WHAT
NORMALLY DONALD TRUMP.
AND IF WE WERE TO POPULAR WE
WERE NOT TO POP AT THE TIME.
IN SOME QUARTERS BEFORE WE
BECAME BEST DEBT DECIDEDLY LESS
SO AS A RESULT MOREOVER SOME
MISPLACED SUPPORTERS.
OF A CERTAIN CANDID OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION.
WHO WE REGISTERED DISCOVERED
THAT WE COULDN'T VOTE IN A
FAVORABLE CANDIDATE?
AS AND SINCE THE DAY AND SINCE
THEY COULD ACCEPT COULD NOT
ACCEPT.
THE CONCLUSIONS THEY JUST
WEREN'T TOO BRIGHT.
WE HAVE THIS INTOLERABLE BAD
REMEDY TO MAKE MINOR PROBLEM.
WELL THIS MARINE HAS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION AMOUNT
TO A FRONTAL ASSAULT OF A MAJOR
OBSTACLE.
WHICH IS SIMPLER AND CHEAPER
THAN WHAT WE DO NOW FOR
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY ELECTION
PERIOD IS.
JUST -- ALL THE CABINETS IN ONE
PARTY REGISTRATION OR MID
INDEPENDENT CANDIDATES WHO WOULD
RUN IN GENERAL ACTIONSIS NOW.
INTO A SINGLE BALLOT GROUP BY
CANDIDATE PARTY AFFILIATION THE
VOTERS PICKED A FAVORITE.
AND AND THEIR JOB IS DONE THE
VOTE IS BEING MADE IN A
POLITICAL PRIMARY OF THE PRIMARY
VEHICLE AND AND WHICH TO WHICH
THE CANDIDATE IS AFFILIATED.
IF YOU WANTED EMERGENCY LIKE
THAT IF YOU WANT SOME EMERGED TO
LEGISLATE LEGISLATE THAT SIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WITHIN TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH AND GET YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
I AM -- PHELPS HOBART.
ON THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE.
THE CHAIRMAN OF FOR THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY [inaudible]
OF IMAGES STATE ARE YOU AGREE
WITH OUR CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR --
LEAVE WELL ENOUGH ALONE DON'T
CHANGE THE NAME THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHEN THIS.
MY NAME IS CITY WEBER SACRAMENTO
HIGH NOT SPEAKING FOR ANY
ORGANIZATION.
I'M BASICALLY ASKING FOR A AN
AMENDMENT.
COUPLE YEARS AGO -- IT THANK YOU
YEAH YOU WERE AT THE POINT OF OF
NAME ORGANIZATION AND OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAD
THREE WITNESSES.
SPEAK TO THE BILL -- GREATLY
EXCEEDING THE TIME THAT WE
USUALLY.
PROVIDE BECAUSE OF MY MISTAKE ON
THE FOR SIDE -- SO IF YOU WANT
TO SUGGEST AMENDMENTS PLEASE
SUBMIT THEM IN WRITING.
I DID AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
LOOKED AT HIM OKAY THANK YOU SEE
DO YOU LIKE IT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT A
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE VICE CHAIR
MISTER MAYES THAN ANYONE ELSE.
STILL I MEAN FOR ME THIS BOILS
DOWN TO A DISAPPEAR
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE -- THIS IS
A PARTY THAT'S HAD THAT NAME
SINCE AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT THERE IS IT
THAT THE FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION
ISSUE IS IS ONE OF THE PARTIES.
AND THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE NAME THAT THEY'VE HAD
FOR THE LAST. FIFTY PLUS YEARS --
AND FOR US TO COME IN AND SAY
HEY WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE YOUR
NAY ESSENTIALLY FORCE THEM. TO
CHANGE THEIR NAME YOU KNOW THE
YOU KIND OF IT SEEMS LIKE PEOPLE
KIND OF CUT AROUND THE EDGES
THIS YES FIRST YOU WOULD NEED A
COMPELLING STATE INTEREST TO DO
SO BECAUSE IT WOULD CLEARLY BE A
FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUE.
YOU NEED A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST IN HOW TO BE NARROWLY
TAILORED. TO ACCOMPLISH THE
PURPOSE.
AND HERE I I DON'T KNOW THAT A
COMPELLING STATE INTEREST IS
THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE CONFUSED.
AND ANYBODY COULD READ THEIR
PLATFORM ANYBODY COULD GO ON AND
LOOK AND SEE WHAT THEIR PARTY IS
ABOUT AND DECIDE WHETHER NOT TO
BE PART OF THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY OR NOT -- THE
FACT THAT OUR ELECTORATE.
YOU KNOW MAY NOT UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE VOTING FOR
I MEAN AT I THINK THERE'S PEOPLE
AROUND THIS ROOM WHO WOULD ARGUE
THAT.
YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
ELECTIONS ALL THE TIME THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARILY -- WELL INFORMED.
IF YOU WILL -- BUT I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST AGO FORCE THEM.
YOU KNOW -- TO TO CHANGE OF A
PARTY NAME TO DO SO -- AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO BE NARAL NARROWLY
TAILORED I MEAN IF YOU WANTED TO
GET OUT THAT ISSUE OF VOTER
CONFUSION.
THE STATE HAS RESOURCES TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE IN FACT WE HAVE A
BILL.
MOVING THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THREE NOTICES TO GO OUT -- TO
VOTERS BEFORE -- BEFORE THE
PRIMARY ELECTION I BELIEVE IT IS --
JUST SO DON'T KNOW HEY ARE YOU
SURE THIS IS THE PARTY YOU WANT
TO BE REGISTERED WITH -- AND AND
AND ALSO TO KNOW A IF YOU WANT
IT WOULD.
BE A A TRUE INDEPENDENT AND BILL
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY FOR
INSTANCE -- YOU KNOW SO THAT THE
STATE HAS ITS OWN RESOURCES TO
GET INFORMATION OUT THERE TO
VOTERS WHO MIGHT BE CONFUSED --
AND THAT WOULD BE A MUCH LESS.
THAT WOULD BE A MORE NARROWLY
TAILORED WAY OF GETTING OUT THAT
PURPOSE THEN MAKING A PARTY
THAT'S EXISTED FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS CHANGE ITS NAME -- AND SO
I MEAN I THINK.
EVEN IF YOU'RE ABLE TO GET THIS
BILL PASSED IT'S GONNA GET
STRUCK DOWN BY THE COURTS.
AND TO ME I JUST.
I THINK THERE'S OTHER THINGS WE
COULD DO TO HELP BETTER EDUCATE.
THE THE THE VOTING PUBLIC AND
THAT'S KIND OF LARGE HOUSE LOOK
AS NOT ANSWER THE GOVERNMENT'S
JOB TO DO.
IT'S I THINK ALL OF OUR JOBS TO
DO IS TO HELP EDUCATE PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT THAT'S PART OF WHAT I
DO AS A REPRESENTATIVE.
I THINK EVERYBODY AROUND THIS
TABLE DOES THAT -- BUT THIS JUST
SEEMS LIKE A VERY DRASTIC
[inaudible]
AND AT USING A HAMMER -- WHEN
YOU COULD USE A SCALPEL --
APPROACH.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE THE REASON
BEHIND IT AND THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND IT.
THE MEN'S RESTROOM IS.
I THANK YOU SENATOR -- FOR FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD -- I KNOW
THAT.
AT LEAST ON OUR SIDE THERE IS --
RECOMMENDATION IS IS AN
OPPOSITION BUT I I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED -- FOR IT BECAUSE OF
THERE CERTAINLY IS NO DOUBT --
THAT OF VOTERS ARE CONFUSED WHEN
THEY'RE REGISTERING TO VOTE AND
A RIP BUT THEN THEY AND WHEN
THEY REGISTER THAT THEY OFTEN
TIMES -- THEY WANT TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND SO THEY GO TO
THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY --
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT --
THERE'S THE REALLY THREE WORDS
AND AN AMERICAN -- POLITICAL
LEXICON IT'S YOUR DEMOCRATS YOUR
REPUBLICAN OR YOU'RE NEITHER OF
THEM YOU'RE AN INDEPENDENT AND
OF COURSE THERE'S THE GREEN
PARTY LIBERTARIAN PARTY.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE THINK THAT
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT.
MAYBE THEY'RE INDEPENDENT SO
THEY'RE GOING TO REGISTER TO
VOTE AND THEY GO DOWN THE THE
LIST OF OPTIONS THEY DON'T LOOK
IT NO PARTY PREFERENCE THEY
DON'T LOOK AT DECLINE TO STATE.
BILL ACCORDS INDEPENDENT AT
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S WHO I WANT
TO BE I WANT TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT -- BUT NOT
NECESSARILY ESTABLISHED WITH THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- I DO THINK
THE BILL IS INCOMPLETE --
HOWEVER BECAUSE I FEEL AS THOUGH
IF WE'RE GONNA DO THIS THEN WE
NEED TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IF
YOU'RE NEITHER A DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN OR GO OR GREEN PARTY
LIBERTARIAN.
THE YOU ARE ACTUALLY AN
INDEPENDENT YOU CAN CHECK A BOX
IS INDEPENDENT I'M NOT DECLINE
TO STATE AND NOTE FOR NOTE NO
PARTY PREFERENCE AND I FEEL LIKE
IF WE GO DOWN THIS ROAD WE
SHOULD ADD THAT SO -- MAYBE WE
CAN WORK ON THAT AND THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION -- BUT I
THINK.
THAT.
USING THE TERM INDEPENDENT MAKES
A MAKES SENSE -- AND THEN YOU
KNOW TO THOSE WHO DON'T LIKE THE
NAME CHANGE UNDERSTAND THE THE
NAMES BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME BUT I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL --
ON PAGE.
FOUR AND THEIR ONLINE -- SIX
WILLIS DEADLINE FOR IT SAYS THE
SECRETARY STATE SHALL NOTIFY
EACH VOTER REGISTERED TO A PARTY
DESCRIBED IN THIS SECTION AS
FOLLOWS.
AND THEN IT SAYS IF THE PARTY
LAWFULLY CHANGES ITS NAME AS
PROVIDED IN THIS SECTION AND
NOTICE SHALL BE SENT INFORMING
THE VOTER OF THE PARTIES NEW
NAME.
THAT THE VOTER SHALL CONTINUE TO
BE REGISTERED TO THE PARTY BUT
UNDER THE NEW NAME.
AND SO FOR THIS IDEA THAT SOME
ALL MY GOSH PEOPLE AREN'T GOING
TO REGISTER FROM THAT'S NOT TRUE
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY REGISTERED
AS AN AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
THEY'LL CONTINUE. TO BE
REGISTERED UNDER THE NEW NAME OF
THE PARTY SO WON'T HARM HARM
THEM NOW OF COURSE AFTERWARDS
THEY LOOK AT IT AWAY I'M NOT
REGISTERED TO THAT AND THEY CAN
DECIDE. TO CHANGE SO I THINK
THAT'S CRAFTED WELL I JUST THINK
IT'S INCOMPLETE -- I THINK -- WE
NEED TO TO TO BRING BACK THAT
TERM INDEPENDENT HAS SOMEBODY
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO BE PART OF
OF OF ANY OF THE OF THE PARTY.
OR ANY OF THE PARTIES -- AND
MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR I DON'T
LIKE IN PP I DON'T LIKE THE T.
S. IN THESE COULD BE NEEDS TO BE
INDEPENDENT.
THEY MUST MAYES CALDERON.
THANK YOU AND I AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER MAYES WHEN
IT COMES RESPECT OF THIS ISSUE I
COME FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE -- AS A MILLENNIAL
AND UNDERSTANDING -- THE IMPACT
OF THIS COULD HAVE ON FUTURE
GENERATIONS I I DON'T THINK THIS
IS NECESSARILY ISSUE OF PICKING.
WINNERS LOSERS BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT PARTY PLATFORMS AND
SEE THIS IS A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED ISSUE BECAUSE WE DON'T
LIKE A PRESIDENT OR NOT THIS IS
MORE ABOUT CREATING A SYSTEM
THAT'S CLEAR AND CONCISE.
I'M OF THE OPINION I DO NOT.
I DON'T LIKE THAT YOU HAVE IT'S
NOT CLEAR YOU HAVE NO PARTY
PREFERENCE DECLINE TO STATE
AMERICAN AND IT'S YEAH IT'S NOT.
SET CLEARLY IF I'M AN
INDEPENDENT VOTER WHAT'S DAHLE I
DO I DO AND YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE
GENERATION THAT IS.
IT EITHER.
BEGINNING TO REGISTER TO VOTE
HAS BEEN REGISTERED TO VOTE --
THAT THEY'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHERE THEY FALL BUT WHAT THEY DO
KNOW IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY SIGNING UP TO BE A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
BUYING ALL IN TO ONE PARTY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE DEFINED BY
HAVING A D. BY THEIR NAME OR BY
HAVING AN ARE BY THEIR NAME
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SUBSCRIBE
ENTIRELY. TO WHAT EITHER OF
THOSE PARTIES REPRESENT THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
OKAY HERE'S A CANDIDATE THIS IS
WHAT THEY STAND FOR THIS IS WHAT
THEY REPRESENT AND THAT'S HOW
THIS IS HOW IT ALIGNS WITH MY
VALUES IS NOT THAT THEY'RE
DEMOCRAT OR THE REPUBLICAN WHICH
IS WHY I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THEM.
IT'S WHO THEY ARE AS THE PRESENT
PERSON WHAT THEY BRING TO
GOVERNMENT THE KIND OF CHANGE IN
THE IDEAS THAT THEY SUPPORT THAT
I SUPPORT I WANT TO SUPPORT THAT
INDIVIDUAL.
AND SELL THEIR NEEDS IT NEEDS TO
BE CLEAR.
WHEN I SIGN UP AND I WANT TO BE
AN INDEPENDENT?
IT'S NOT CLEAR.
BECAUSE I HAVE TOO MANY OPTIONS
THE LABEL ME AN INDEPENDENT.
BUT WHEN I TAUGHT WHEN I LISTEN
TO REGARDLESS OF ITS FOX NEWS.
CNN MSNBC ALL OF THEM THERE ARE
THREE PARTIES THERE THERE ARE
THREE CLASSIFICATIONS DEMOCRAT
REPUBLICAN OR INDEPENDENT.
THERE'S NOT DECLINE TO STATE NO
PARTY PREFERENCE OR ANYBODY ELSE
AND SO THERE NEED TO BE MORE
CLARITY ON THIS ISSUE.
SO THAT WE ARE NOT RUNNING INTO
AN ISSUE WHERE WE ARE.
OUR OUR HAVING PEOPLE THAT ARE
SIGNING UP. FOR SPECIFIC PARTIES
THAT HAVE CERTAIN PLATFORMS.
REGARDLESS OF THIS BORDER NOT --
THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SIGNING UP FOR AND WHAT
THE THEY THEY THINK IT'S ONE
THING WHEN THEY'RE TIGHT WHAT
WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE SIGNING UP
FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
AND SO -- WHEN IT COMES OF THIS
ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
CLARITY AND I I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON ON
THAT ISSUE MAYBE WE ADD THAT IN --
AND CONTINUE TO IN A WORK WITH
OPPOSITION ANYWAY THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN BUT AT THIS TIME I
I DO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
I'M GONNA.
MAKE A MOTION THANK YOU ALSO
WILL BE A MOTION.
IN VERSE SECOND.
WE HAVE A SECOND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S JUST.
AND JUST WANT.
TO CLARIFY THAT THERE AMENDMENTS
TO ADD AN URGENCY BECAUSE AND
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE DIESEL IN
COMMON FOR ONE OF THE ANALYSIS.
ANY DIGITAL FROM COLLEAGUES THAT
WEBER.
I WANT TO THANK.
WITH SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- I ASKED A COUPLE
PEOPLE THAT I KNOW WHO BELIEVE
THEIR INDEPENDENT WHO SIGNED UP
FOR THIS AND NONE OF THEM HAD
EVER READ ANYTHING ABOUT IT IS A
FAIRLY INTELLIGENT PEOPLE.
AND WHEN THEY READ IT THEY SAID
THIS IS NOT WHAT I STAND FOR IN
TERMS OF A PARTY.
AND I I WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
I THINK TO MAKE THINGS VERY
CLEAR -- TO INDIVIDUALS AND NOT
TO DECEIVE THEM WE'VE BEEN ON
THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF TRANSPARENCY
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT --
THAT WE MAKE THINGS AS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE SO PEOPLE CAN CHOOSE
WHAT THEY REALLY BELIEVE.
AND AND WHAT THEY REALLY WANT TO
BE A PART OF AND SOME FOLKS WHO
ARE VERY DISGUSTED WITH ALL
PARTIES WANT TO BE INDEPENDENT.
AND THEY THINK THEY ARE WHEN
THEY SIGN UP FOR THIS THEY THEY
THINK THEY ARE AND THEN THEY
REPEAT WHAT THE PARTIES ABOUT AN
OUT STARTED AND GEORGE WALLACE
IN AUSTIN AGO GOD NO THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M ABOUT AND I SAID BUT
THAT'S WHAT YOU SIGNED UP.
FOR SO I THINK IT IT REALLY IS --
YOU KNOW IT SOUNDS DIFFICULT TO
TO HAVE TO GO AND DO THIS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME IF YOU REALLY.
JUST KNOWING HOW FOLKS ARE AND
WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO BE
INDEPENDENT YOU HEAR THE TERM
INDEPENDENT AND AND AND AND MANY
OF THEM AND WEEKS WE'VE
OURSELVES OF CONFUSE PEOPLE WITH
THIS OPEN PRIMARY THAT ISN'T
REALLY OPEN.
AND ALL THOSE OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS THAT PEOPLE GET REALLY
CONFUSED AND THEY THEN THEY GET
FRUSTRATED WHEN THEY TRY TO VOTE.
OF FOR PARTICULAR PARTY OR FILL
OUT A FORM AND DISCOVER THAT
THEY CAN'T VOTE BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT THEY DIDN'T
THINK THEY WERE IN A PARTY BUT
THEY WERE BEING INDEPENDENT AND
THEY COULD VOTE REPUBLICAN A
DEMOCRAT.
IN THE PRIMARY NOW THEY CAN'T
AND THEY'RE FRUSTRATED AS IF
WE'VE CONDOM AND AS A RESULT
THEY LOSE ALL KINDS OF INTEREST
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
BECAUSE THEY FEEL DECEIVED SO I
THINK IS IS MANY THINGS WE CAN
DO TO TRY TO CREATE CLARITY FOR
VOTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THERE IS NO.
UNDERLYING.
MOTIVE IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
TO SHIP THEM INTO A CERTAIN
DIRECTION THE BETTER WE ARE AND
OF THE FEW PEOPLE I ASKED ABOUT
THIS WHO.
LOOKED AT IT IT AND FELT THAT
THEY HAD BEEN TO SEE THAT THEY
HAD SIGNED UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT THEY TRULY WERE FAR FAR
AWAY FROM.
IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN POLITICS
AND HAD NO IDEA THAT THERE
REALLY WAS A PARTY THEY LOOK FOR
INDEPENDENT THEY WANT TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND THEY DID THAT.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO CLARIFY TO MAKE
SURE THAT VOTERS ACTUALLY
SIGNING OF WHAT THEY WANT.
AND AND DO THAT I THINK ALSO WE
WE NEED TO MOVE ALSO IS POOR
SOMEONE POINTED OUT TO A
CATEGORY OF INDEPENDENT SO
PEOPLE CAN JUST SEE THAT UP
FRONT RATHER THAN HAVING.
TO KIND OF WAIT THE WHOLE BUNCH
OF STUFF TO FIND IT BUT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION -- I APPRECIATE THE
RESEARCH HAS FINALLY BEEN DONE
THAT MOST OF THIS KIND OF KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT BUT IT'S NOW
CODIFIED AND AND HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS REALLY
CONFUSING. TO PEOPLE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU DOCTOR
EVER DONE.
CALDERON AND IT MADE MAYBE PART
OF THE CONSIDERATION IS RATHER
THAN TAKING PARTIES LIKE THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
ELIMINATING INDEPENDENT BECAUSE
IT'S THE CAUSES CONFUSION IT'S
JUST.
GETTING RID OF NOT DECLINE TO
STATE NO PARTY PREFERENCE IN
CREATING AN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
AND THEN IT WOULD STAND NEXT TO
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT THAT'S JUST
A SUGGESTION BUT I HOPE YOU
CONSIDER.
CHOOSE WHICHEVER BERMAN -- YES I
APOLOGIZE SIR WE WE WE DON'T
HAVE A A BACK AND FORTH WITH
FOLKS YEAH IN LESS AND LESS THE
QUESTION GETS ASKED THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
WE GOT A COUPLE ALL RIGHT ROUND
DO I WILL I WILL DECIDE AND HOW
OLD IS AND YOU KNOW WITH.
ASK YOURSELF THIS QUESTION HOW
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE REGISTERED
RIGHT NOW AS REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
TRULY KNOW AND HAVE READ THE
PLATFORM OF BOTH OF THOSE
PARTIES.
AND KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT IT AND
AND AND MAYBE ONLY REGISTERED
THAT WAY BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
ARE REGISTERED THAT WHERE FOR
WHATEVER REASON -- DON'T TRULY
HAVE AN INFORMED KNOWLEDGE OF
WHY THEY'RE REGISTERED -- YOU
KNOW THAT WAY HOW IS THAT ANY
DIFFERENT.
FROM THE SITUATION YOU KNOW OR
THAT THINK THAT MAYBE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MEANS.
I SUPPORT DEMOCRACY OR A
REPUBLICAN PARTY MEANS I SUPPORT
REPUBLICAN FORMER GOVERNOR YEAH
I MEAN.
YOU CAN MAKE THESE ARGUMENTS
ABOUT ANY NUMBER OF THOSE THINGS
AND SO.
IT REALLY LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE ONLY
YOU'RE ONLY PICKING ON ONE PARTY.
AND AND EVENTUALLY LIKE THAT'S
GONNA NOT PASS CONSTITUTIONAL
MUSTER PERIOD HE WAS RIGHT THERE
IN A MISTER MAYES AND THEN
DOCTOR WEBER MOTHER HAD A FOLLOW
UP.
OR OR OR NOT OR OR MAYBE THEY'LL
BE FOR AFTER THE HEARING I KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IS IN ITS SECOND
HOUSE SO IN REGARDS TO MENDING
IT -- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THE
THAT THAT CAN BE DIFFICULT I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS ORIFICE JUDGES
COME TO COMING TO THE FLOOR BUT
I WONDER IF THE SENATOR WOULD BE
OPEN -- TO I THINK MISTER
CALDERON RIGHT KIND OF ON THE
SAME -- SABLE SAME WAVELENGTH
HERE IN REGARDS TO THE LET'S
LET'S CALL AN INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT WHEN SOMEBODY GOES
THE BAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT WOULD
BE A PARTY BUT IF THEY WANTED TO
REGISTER AS AN INDEPENDENT.
LET'S CALL IT -- THAT WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO TO TO
HAVING SOME CONVERSATIONS IN
TRYING TO CREATE SOME SOME
CLARITY SO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AB AS
MISTER JONES.
A NOTED TO US THE OTHER DAY I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS JUST
RECENTLY SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX AND TWO THOUSAND SIX I HAVE
A BILL DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SUGGESTED -- IT FAILED -- BUT
YOUR YOUR SUGGESTION IS WILL
TAKE IT UP IN IN MY CLOTHES ALL
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE BUT NO I I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT I THINK THAT.
IT WOULD BE.
A BETTER. TO HAVE DECLINED THE
STATE'S REGISTER AS INDEPENDENCE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK
THEY ARE -- INTO WHETHER IT GETS.
INCORPORATED INTO THIS AWARE
THAT'S ANOTHER SEPARATE EFFORT
THAT SOMETHING WILL HAVE TO
CONSIDER.
IN AND THE BILL WILL GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS FOR FOR
CLARIFICATION.
NOT MAYBE MISTER KALRA HAVE
SOMETHING NEXT YEAR THEY ARE
RARE.
BILLS READY I MEAN WE JUST HAVE
TO PULL OF THE ARCHIVES THE
RIGHT.
SET UP IT'S BEEN WRITTEN NEW
MODEL NUMBER.
THE I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAD
ARCHIVES THAT BUT THANK YOU --
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES --
CENTER EMBER YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
IN AND LET ME -- INCORPORATING
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE WITH
THE COMMENTS OF OF VARIOUS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WITH
RESPECT TO THE NEED FOR THE BILL
HERE'S HERE'S WHAT WE NOW.
WE KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE
REGISTERED AS AN AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY MEMBER YOU
CANNOT VOTE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY HOWEVER IF YOU ARE.
A DECLINE TO STATE WHICH MOST
PEOPLE TRADITIONALLY THINK OF AS
AN INDEPENDENT YOU CAN'T WHETHER
REPUBLICAN PARTY PERMITS THAT
ARE NOT.
THAT'S A SEPARATE QUESTION BUT
THEY MAY WELL.
ADOPT THE SAME RULES AS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH AGAIN
WOULD PRECLUDE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY MEMBER FROM
VOTING IN THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
SO WE KNOW THAT.
THAT EXISTS TODAY WE ALSO KNOW
THE EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING
THAT THOSE WHO ARE REGISTERED
THE AS AMERICAN INDEPENDENCE --
IN LARGE PART OBVIOUSLY NOT ALL
BUT LARGE PART REGISTERED
BECAUSE THEY TRULY WANTED TO BE.
INDEPENDENT OF THE QUESTION
RAISED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER IS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST I OBVIOUSLY DO BELIEVE
IT'S A COMPELLING STATE INTEREST
I THINK THAT THE EVIDENCE WILL
DEMONSTRATE THAT IT'S A
COMPELLING.
STATE INTEREST TO ENSURE THAT
VOTERS ARE NOT DECEIVED IN SO
THAT VOTERS CAN FULLY EXERCISE
THEIR FRANCHISE -- IN IN THE
UPCOMING ELECTION AND IN FUTURE
ELECTIONS -- BUT I SUPPOSE
REASONABLE MINDS MIGHT DIFFER --
AND IF IF IT DOES GO TO THE
COURT HI I THINK THAT.
ON BALANCE THE COURT WILL FIND
THAT THERE IS A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST IN IN.
PREVENTING SORT OF OF OBVIOUS AN
INTENTIONAL VOTER CONFUSION.
SO HAVING SAID THAT I WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THE CENTER -- WHILE AND WELL IT
IS A SIGNIFICANT STEP TO REQUIRE
POLITICAL PARTY TO CHANGES NAME.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF VOTERS
WHO DO NOT WANT TO BE AFFILIATED
WITH POLITICAL PARTIES ARE
MISTAKENLY REGISTERING WITH THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
AND THAT MISTAKE CAN PREVENT
VOTERS FROM BEING ABLE TO VOTE
FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
OF THEIR CHOICE WHICH I AGREE IS
A COMPELLING STATE INTEREST --
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WITH A PROPOSED AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THAT ADD AN URGENCY
CLAUSE TO THE BILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
AYE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON I LOW.
WELL I MAYES.
MAYES ON A MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
THE BILL IS OUT WITH FIVE VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN TRAPS
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GEN THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
I SEE CENTER WIENER IN THE CROWD
YOU'VE GOT TO ITEM SIR ADAM FOUR
ADAM.
FIVE SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT IN
[inaudible]
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WE ARE YOU GUYS
SO [inaudible]
YEAH -- WE HAVE A
OKAY BUT WAY
SHOULD OF AND SO -- FIRST I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE TECHNICAL IN
THE OR THE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS -- IN ADDITION --
WE'VE REACHED A FURTHER --
AGREEMENT -- ANOTHER MOMENT THAT
I WILL ACCEPT -- AND THAT WILL
CHANGE IN THE BILL INSTEAD OF
REQUIRING THAT THE BALLOT LABEL
STATE QUOTE SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR
INFORMATION.
INSTEAD IT WILL STATE QUOTE SEE
VOTER GUIDE FOR TAX RATES
INFORMATION AND QUOTE SO -- THAT
MEMINTA THE ANALYSIS AND DOT
AMENDMENT WERE HAPPY -- TO
EXCEPT AND AGAIN WE THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US -- BECAUSE
THIS SONG LEGISLATION IT ARISES
OUT OF TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH THE STATED GOAL
OF INCREASING TRANSPARENCY FOR
BONDS AND PARCEL TAX MEASURES.
REQUIRING THAT IN THE SEVENTY
FIVE WORD OP BALLOT QUESTION
ABOUT LABEL -- DIE CERTAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT -- TAX RATES
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE INCLUDED --
WHILE THIS APPROACH MAKES SENSE
FOR A VERY SIMPLE TAXES SUCH AS
SALES TAX OR A STRAIGHT UP --
PARCEL TAX WITH ONLY ONE RATE
WITH NO EXEMPTIONS -- FOR BONDS
OR FOR MORE COMPLICATED PARCEL
TAXES -- IT DOESN'T WORK AND SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
HI OF RIGHT NOW I HAVE A PURE --
A MULTI TIER PARCEL TAX -- AND
WE FREQUENTLY HAVE PARCEL TAXES
WHERE FOR EXAMPLE COMMERCIAL
MIGHT PAY MORE THAN RESIDENTIAL
OR MIGHT BE TIERED BASED ON THE
SIZE OF A PROPERTY OR THE VALUE
OF PRO OR THE OR OTHER --
FACTORS OR YOU MIGHT HAVE A
SENIOR EXEMPTION OR A LOW INCOME
EXEMPTION -- AND UNDER THE LAW
AS IT IS NOW FOR A PARCEL TAX IN
THAT SEVENTY FIVE WORDS YOU HAVE.
TO YOU HAVE TO DESCRIBE EVERY
SINGLE TEAR -- AND WHEN YOU HAVE
MORE THAN ONE TEAR.
ON IT BECOMES PHYSICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIT IT WITH IN
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS THIS IS ONE
OF PARTICULAR -- PARTIAL TAX
QUESTION.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE HAVE
BEEN IN BLACK UP TO THOSE
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS AND AFTER
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS IT'S GREAT
OUT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT UNDER THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS TWENTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN THIS PARCEL TAX WOULD
EFFECTIVELY BECOME ILLEGAL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND
WEBELIEVE THE OVERWHELMINGLY
TIERED PARCEL TAXES EVEN SIMPLE
ONES OUT PROVIDE ONE OR TWO
EXEMPTIONS TO SENIOR TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE.
OUGHT WOULD EFFECTIVELY BE
PROHIBITED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD AND FORCE
US TO HAVE MORE REGRESSIVE
TAXATION BECAUSE THE ONLY KIND
OF PARCEL TAX YOU COULD EVER DO.
IS A FLAT PARCEL TAX THAT
EVERYONE PAYS THE SAME THE
MATTER HOW RICH OR POOR WEATHER
A BIG COMMERCIAL BUILDING OR A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
ALSO ON PARTS YOUR PARCEL TAXES
THE THE THE LEGISLATION
EFFECTIVELY BANS ON ONE BONDS --
THE IT ALSO CREATES SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS FIRST OF ALL IT
REQUIRES A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT TAKES AWAY FROM
THE SEVENTY FIVE OR A
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THE BOND
ACTUALLY DIES AND MAKES IT A LOT
HARDER -- FOR CITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DESCRIBE WHAT THE
BOND DOES AN ACCURATE WAY.
IT ALSO CREATES SIGNIFICANT
CONFUSION BECAUSE YOUR OUGHT WE
KNOW THAT IN TERMS OF THE TAX
IMPACT OF BONDS YOU CAN'T
PREDICT WHAT IT IS WHEN YOU GO
TO THE BALLOT.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE INTEREST
RATE IS A TIME FOR EXAMPLE AND
SO IT DEPENDS ON WHEN THE BOND
IS SOLD IN A BOND CAN BE SOLD
YEARS.
AFTER THE VOTERS ACTUALLY
AUTHORIZED THE BOND AND SO WHAT
THAT FORCES AUG CITIES TO DO IS
TO LIST EITHER A BLINDING OR AN
AVERAGE -- RANGE AS VERY
SPECULATIVE AND MISLEADING TO
THE VOTERS THE GOAL HERE IS
TRANSPARENCY.
AT A AT A FORCES CITIES TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
PEOPLE WILL PAY ON BONDS.
THAT MAY NOT PERTAIN TO THAT
PARTICULAR.
PERSON THIS IS ALL WITHIN THE
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS WE KNOW THAT
IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN TERMS
OF STATEWIDE THE PERCENTAGES ON
THESE BONDS IMPARTIAL TAXES WENT
DOWN AND WE BELIEVE IT WAS A
REAL AS A RESULT OF OF THIS
CHANGE WE MAKE IT EXCEPTIONALLY
HARD.
IN CALIFORNIA FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO RAISE REVENUE.
WE THEY OVERWHELMINGLY HAVE TO
GET A TWO THIRDS VOTE ON BONDS
WITH THE EXCEPTION SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
A AND ON PARCEL TAXES TWO THIRDS
VOTE IS A VERY VERY HIGH
THRESHOLD ALREADY AND WE SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HEALTH HARDLY
MAKE IT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN THAT THE FUNDING OF LOCAL
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT FIRE
STATIONS THAT CLOSE LIBRARY THIS
NUMBER OF CITIES OF SCALE BACK
OR ELIMINATED THEIR LIBRARY
SYSTEMS.
ROAD PAVING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT WE EXPECT
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE MADE
IT HARD AND WE MADE IT MUCH.
HARDER EVEN HARDER WITH THESE
TWO LAWS -- SO WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO IS -- INSTEAD OF REQUIRE
ALL THAT IN THE SEVENTY FIVE
WORDS TO PUT IT INTO THE VOTER
HANDBOOK WITHOUT INDICATION --
AS AMENDED PER -- OF THE GREEN
WITH THE COMMITTEE SO THE VOTERS
KNOW IF YOU WANT AND FOR MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT TAX
IMPACTS.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE VOTER GUIDE?
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR OF THE TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LAWS THAT
CONSIDER HIM A FRIEND I RESPECT
HIM GREATLY WE HAVE CO AUTHORED
BILLS TOGETHER -- WE SAT DOWN WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR --
BILL AND IT'S NEVER COMFORTABLE --
TO TRY -- TO CHANGE -- REPEAL A
BILL THAT A COLLEAGUE A
RESPECTED COLLEAGUE -- HAS A
AUTHORED BUT I THINK HERE -- WE
NEED TO DO THIS US OF THAT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
CAN ACTUALLY OP FUND THEMSELVES --
AND I THINK THAT THE RESOLUTION
REACH WITH THE COMMITTEE IS A
GOOD ONE USES THE WORD TAX IT'S
RIGHT AND THEIR IN ADDITION TO
IT PROBABLY WILL BE LISTED AS A
PARCEL TAX AT THE BEGINNING OF
IT AS A PARCEL TAX.
SO I THINK THAT THE TRANSPARENCY --
IS MAINTAINED -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY ARTS HIS IDEAS
FROM THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
REBEKAH CURLY FROM THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE ON ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING.
AND ANTHONY TANNER HILL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU THE CENTER
WITNESSES.
AND AND JUST A QUICK REMINDER
WE'RE GONNA ADD TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
REBEKAH CURLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING HERE TODAY AND SUPPORT.
LOCAL BONDS ARE THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF REVENUE TO CONSTRUCT
REPAIR AND UPGRADE SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA
DESERVES A CLEAN SAFE SCHOOL PER
OUR CONSTITUTION -- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE COMMUNICATE
CLEARLY AND ACCURATELY WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES LOCAL BONDS ARE
COVENANTS BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND ABSENT TRUST BETWEEN THESE
TWO WE WON'T BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
OUR BOND PROGRAMS AND TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
RECENT CHANGES TO THE ELECTIONS
COULD MAKE IT SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY
LOW WEALTH DISTRACTS. TO MEET
THEIR OBLIGATIONS HOUSE STUDENTS
WERE ESPECIALLY CONCERNED BY THE
A FAX THAT THE RECENT CHANGES
HAVE ON DISTRICTS ABOUT A
DEMONSTRATED HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING LOCAL BONDS. FOR
LOCAL BONDS AS THE SENATOR
DESCRIBED THE RATE CHARGED TO
PAY PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST
PAYMENTS DOES CHANGE ANNUALLY
BASED ON ECONOMIC FACTORS SUCH
AS INTEREST RATES AND PROPERTY
VALUES.
IN ONE EXAMPLE WE HAD A SCHOOL
WITH A RATE OF NINETEEN DOLLARS
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ASSESSED VALUATION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THEN THE GREAT
RECESSION HIT OUR PROPERTY
VALUES TANKS AND THEY HAD TO
RAISE THAT RATE. TO SIXTY FOUR
DOLLARS THE VERY NEXT YEAR AND
TWENTY TIMES YOU CAN SEE IT'S A
REALLY WIDE SPREAD AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO COMMUNICATE THOUGHT
TO VOTERS.
ON THE SEVENTY FIVE FOR A BALLOT
STATEMENT.
THE ABOUT THAT WE REYES ANNUALLY.
THE AMOUNT OF THE DURATION WILL
ALSO FLUCTUATE.
THE BOTTOM LINE OF ALL OF THIS
IS THAT THE INFORMATION DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FOR LOCAL BONDS AND
WE DON'T HAVE SPACE ON THAT
SEVENTY FIVE OR BALLOTS
STATEMENT TO MAKE THE DETAILED
EXPLANATION.
THE COST OF THIS IS VOTER
CONFUSION WHEN VOTERS ARE
CONFUSED THE TO VOTE NOW AND
EVEN IF IT IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
SUPPORTED WHEN THEY HAD BETTER
INFORMATION REGARDING THEIR
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCE.
LOCAL BONDS ALREADY PROVIDE
DETAILED TAX RATE INFORMATION
AND THE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE
IN THE REQUIRED TAX RATE
STATEMENTS.
THIS IS THE PLACE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY AN
EXPLANATION REGARDING FACTORS
SUCH AS WHY THE RATE MAY CHANGE
PLEASE WRAP UP SB TWO SIXTY
EIGHT AND HAVE SINCE
TRANSPARENCY -- AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SURE MEMBER SAYS THAT IS ONLY
HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
OUR MEMBERS TO A BILL THAT
MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE STATE BUT THERE BE SCHOOLS
FOR FREEWAYS.
OF PORTS I'M MORE OFTEN PARTNERS
WITH OF THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- OF TO PASS
BONDS AND TO ADDRESS THEIR OF
FINANCIAL NEEDS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE -- WE HAVE SEEN
THAT THE BALLOT LABELS OF
CURRENTLY ARE AFFECTING VOTER OF
A GUIDANCE HERE ON THESE ISSUES.
IN FACT I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD WHERE WE
JUST APPROVED.
A A SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT HAD
GONE -- IT WAS BIG ACTUALLY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD
GONE TO THE BALLOT FOUR TIMES TO
GET A LOCAL BOND MEASURE PASSED
AND THEY WERE AFFECTED BY THE
FIRE -- AND OF COURSE THIS STATE
OCCASION BOARD WAS ABLE TO
EXEMPT THE CURRENT REGULATIONS
TO PROVIDE THEM THE NECESSARY
FUNDING THAT THEY PROVIDED.
BUT THEY HAD GONE OUT FOUR TIMES
AND THEY RAN OUT AGAIN IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THE VOTERS IN
THAT AREA ARE VERY CONSERVATIVE --
THE BALLOT LABEL ALONE DID NOT
ALLOW THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
ACTUALLY FULFILL THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR TO THEIR
STUDENTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUT OF THE DEAL
THAT HAS BEEN STRUCK THE BALANCE
THE OLDER HAS BEEN STRUCK BY
YOURSELF IN THE AND THE SENATOR
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
STILL ALLOWS VOTERS TO BE
DIRECTED TO THE VOTER GUIDE I TO
SEE INFORMATION THAT'S WHERE A
LOT OF THE INFORMATION LIVES AND
SHOULD BE.
IT SHOULD NOT BE.
AND THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE BECAUSE
AND IT HINDERS THE ABILITY OF
THAT VOTER TO ACTUALLY MAKING A
GOOD AT A LOSS AS TO WHAT THE
BALANCE NEED ARE FOR OR THE
CRIME IS FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE --
NECESSITY SO FOR THOSE REASONS --
IN A WEEK WE DO WANT TO EXPRESS --
OUR REGRETS FOR MISSING.
TWICE THE THAT MISTER OBERNOLTE
IS BILL AND FULL OF TIP MY HAT
OFF TO HIM BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE THAT HE GOT THIS DONE
BUT WE DO SEE A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
ASSUMING BEFORE THE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT ONE IS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
I ANTHONY TANNER HOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
OUT WE HAVE WE HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF PROVIDE.
KEY LOCAL SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
RANGING FROM HEALTHCARE AND AND
LIBRARIES AND CEMETERIES TO
FIRES SUPPRESSION PROTECTION
WATER AND OTHER SANITATION.
AND WERE WERE EXCITED THAT THIS
IS BEING A DRASTIC COMMAND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS. FOR OUR AND
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR.
FOR PUTTING THOUGH THE WORKING
TIME AND BECAUSE AS YOU'VE HEARD
THIS IS CAUSED.
SOME SOME DILEMMAS IN THE
ABILITY TO TO TO FIND THE
REVENUES AND RAISE THE FINANCES
TO PROVIDE THESE.
CRITICAL.
HYPER LOCAL SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE -- YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE THE TEAR TAX RATES.
OF WHICH COULD BE.
PREFERENTIAL FOR AN ENTERPRISE
ZONE OR AGRICULTURAL LAND VERSUS
RESIDENTIAL OR OTHER TYPES OF
COMMERCIAL.
AND WE JUST SIMPLY CAN'T FITTED
ALMA.
ON THE A BALLOT AS YOU SEE THERE
WITH THE EXAMPLE.
SO AS IT'S BEEN STATED -- BY BY
MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
SENATOR -- THIS IS A GOOD MOVE
FORWARD AND IT'S VITAL FOR US TO
KEEP OUR OUR FINANCES STRAIGHT
FOR LOCAL SERVICES.
RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF YOU PLEASE JUST
GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR PHILLY
ABSOLUTELY -- KEVIN FROM WORTH
THE COP THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SEVENTY ONE WITH A CA YOU
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
NICCOLO DELUCA HERE BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND MAYOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND NONPROFIT HOUSING OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATT ROBERTS IT WITH
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO ALSO STRONG SUPPORT.
A RUSTLE NOVAK ON BEHALF THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVE WALRATH WITH SCHOOL ENERGY
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
JEFF NEAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO SUPPORT.
JEAN HEARSE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ALL IN
SUPPORT.
BART BROOME WITH SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN
AS VALLEY WATER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
A STRANGE BE ON THE SIDE OF THE
TABLE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THE LEGISLATION THAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO EXEMPTS THESE BOND
ISSUANCES FROM WAS BUILT
LEGISLATION THAT I AUTHORED IS
AB EIGHT OH NINE ORIGINALLY AND
THEN AB ONE NINETY FIVE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THE CLARIFIED.
THAT THE TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS EXTENDED TO BOND
ISSUANCES MY MOTIVATION FOR
INTRODUCING THAT LEGISLATION WAS
A STRONG FEELING THAT WE OUGHT
TO BE TRANSPARENT WITH VOTERS
WHEN THEY VOTE ON SOMETHING THAT
INCREASES TAXES ON THE BALLOT.
THAT IT IS INDEED A TAX INCREASE.
AB ONE NINETY FIVE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN BOTH
CHAMBERS EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE VOTED FOR IT.
NOW I WILL BE THE FIRST TO ADMIT
THAT THE LAST OF SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF BEEN RAISED BY THE
SPONSOR HERE ARE COMPLETELY
VALID -- I THINK THAT THE CHAIR
TAX RATES FOR SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD GO IN THE VOTER GUIDE --
I THINK THAT THE SAFE HAVEN THAT
THEY PROPOSED FOR IF THEY'VE
USED A GOOD FAITH ESTIMATE OF
THINGS LIKE BONTA RATIONS --
BOND RATES THAT -- THEY OUGHT TO
BE -- IS LONG AS THEY'VE ACTED
IN GOOD FAITH IF THEY OUGHT TO
BE -- PROTECTED AGAINST
VALIDATION I WOULD AGREE WITH
ALL OF THAT HOWEVER.
I STILL THINK WE NEED TO TELL
THE VOTERS THAT THEY'RE VOTING
ON A TAX INCREASE AND THAT SEEMS
TO BE WHAT THEY WANT TO AVOID
DOING SO.
IN THE YEARS SINCE AB ONE NINETY
FIVE PASSED I HAVE TRIED TWICE
TO WORK WITH THE SPONSOR.
IN RECTIFYING THE SITUATION AND
THEY HAVE OPPOSED MY LEGISLATION
BOTH TIMES BECAUSE THE ONE THING
I'M NOT WILLING TO DO.
IS TO AVOID TELLING VOTERS THAT
THEY'RE VOTING ON A TAX INCREASE.
SO.
I DON'T WANT TO VILIFY THE
SPONSORS HERE REALIZE THAT THEY
HAVE A JOB TO DO.
AND THE THE REPRESENTING THEIR
INTERESTS BUT WE HAVE A JOB TO
DO TO IN OUR JOB IS TO BE THE
FULCRUM BETWEEN SPECIAL
INTERESTS ON ONE SIDE.
AND TAXPAYER PROTECTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S UNREASONABLE TO TELETEXT
PLAYERS THAT THEY'RE VOTING ON A
TAX INCREASE.
SO TALKING ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL JUST REQUIRES THAT
EVERYTHING GO IN THE VOTER GUIDE
AND THAT THE ONLY THING ON THE
BALLOT STATEMENT SAY AS AMENDED
DOW. FIVE C..
VOTER GUIDE FOR TAX RATE
INFORMATION RIGHT SO.
YOU COULD SAY [inaudible]
THIS MEASURE.
IT REDUCES THE BOND THAT WERE
CURE CANCER AND PROVIDE A FREE
PUPPY FOR EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA.
SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR TAX RATE
INFORMATION I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S BEING TRANSPARENT.
SOME SOLUTIONS THAT I HAVE
OFFERED.
WERE FIRST I OFFERED.
I PUT EVERYTHING THE VOTER GUIDE
AND LET'S SAY.
THIS MEASURE INCREASES PROPERTY
TAXES SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR
INFORMATION.
I WAS TOLD THAT NO YOU CAN'T SAY
TAX INCREASE THAT THAT'S A NON
STARTER.
SO I SAID OKAY ABOUT THIS.
THIS MEASURE AFFECTS TAX RATES
SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR INFORMATION.
AND THAT WAS REJECTED ALSO.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT REALLY GOES
TO THE MOTIVATION HERE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
[inaudible]
UP.
IF THIS SHOULD NOT PASSED TODAY
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO EITHER
VOTE NOR JUST TO LAY OFF A WE
WORK THIS OUTI WILL PLEDGE TO
TRY A THIRD TIME NEXT YEAR TO
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
SPONSOR.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT.
I WILL NOT DO IS TO AGREE TO TRY
AN OBSCURE FROM THE VOTER THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE INDEED
VOTING ON SOMETHING THAT WILL IN
FACT.
INCREASE TAXES AND I DON'T THINK
YOU SHOULD.
TOO AND LASTLY I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOMETHING THAT HAD BEEN
BROUGHT UP WHICH IS THE
PERCEIVED DIFFICULTY OF PASSING.
THESE BOND ISSUANCES ON THE
BALLOT.
THERE IS ANALYSIS HERE.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT YOU
OF THAT -- YOU RECEIVED ON THIS
BILL ALL OF THE MEASURES THAT
WERE PROPOSED LAST YEAR.
THAT PUT BOND INCREASES ON
BALLOTS IN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED OF THEM AND
THE PASSAGERATE.
WAS OVER 82%.
SO I DON'T ACCEPT THE FACT THAT
THIS IS PREVENTING OTHERWISE
GOOD BOND ISSUANCES FROM PASSING
AND IN FACT I THINK IF WE EVER
GET TO A 100%.
TAX PASSAGE RATE THAT THAT WOULD
BE INDICATIVE OF A DIFFERENT
PROBLEM SO I WOULD DOT URGE YOU
TO EITHER VOTE NO OR LAY OFF AND
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
OUT SOMETHING THAT BALANCES THE
NEED. TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS WITHIN RAISED WITH
PROTECTION OF TAXPAYERS.
THE MEASURE WANT OBERNOLTE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
DAVID WILL FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION -- IN
OPPOSITION AND FORTUNATELY DEBTS
BE TWO SIXTY EIGHT MEMBERS OF MR
WROTE -- OBERNOLTE MENTION WE DO
HAVE A LONG AND STORIED HISTORY
WITH THIS CODE SECTION WE WERE
THE SPONSORS OF BOTH AB EIGHT OR
NINE AND AB.
ONE OH FIVE AND MEMBERS AS EVEN
MISTER WERE NORTH YOU MENTION WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS INFORMATION
CAN BE DIFFICULT TO LESS THAN A
SEVENTY FIVE WORD ABOUT LABEL WE
TO HAVE WORKED WITH CASH AND
OTHERS.
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS OUT OF
RECOGNITION ON THIS PROBLEM TO
TRY AND REACH SOME SORT OF
AMENDMENT IN CONCLUSION THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY WORK WHILE STILL
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO
TAXPAYERS AND AS MR WHEN
OBERNOLTE MENTION OF COURSE --
THERE'S OVERTURES WERE REJECTED
WE UNDERSTAND THINGS LIKE BONDS
ARE SOLD IN SERIES AND AREN'T
SOLD EVERY YEAR IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THAT
INFORMATION ON A SEVENTY FIVE OR
A BALLOT LABEL.
BUT AS THE ASSEMBLYMAN ALSO
MENTIONED JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING
IS DIFFICULT DOES NOT MEAN IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE.
CAL TAX -- AS THE SOME WOMEN
MENTIONED NOTED THAT THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN OF
THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT LOCAL
TAX AND BOND MEASURES PLACED ON
THE BALLOT IN THE LAST ELECTION
CYCLE SINCE THESE BILLS A BAN IN
PLACE WERE PROOF.
THAT IS AN 82% PASSAGE RATE IT'S
NOT AS IF THESE DON'T PASS WITH
THAT REQUIRED TRANSPARENCY
INFORMATION IN PLACE -- WE DO
BELIEVE MEMBERS THAT THE
INFORMATION SHOULD BE IN ABOUT
LEVEL IN A MANNER THAT MAKES
SENSE TO VOTERS.
AND MAYBE LISTEN IF WE CAN
EXPLAIN THE NUANCES OF A BOND
MEASURE IN SEVENTY FIVE RATES
MAYBE WE SHOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PORTS.
MAYBE WE SHOULD LIMIT THE
SEVENTY FIVE WORD BALLOT LABEL
DIGEST THE RATE DURATION AND
AMOUNT OF REVENUE TO BE RAISED
AND SAVE ALL THE FLOWERY HEY
THIS IS WHAT THE BINDING TAX
GOES TO SUPPORT.
PUT THAT SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BECAUSE LISTEN THESE MEASURES
ARE ON PROPERTY TAX BILLS THEY
ARE INEFFECTIVE FOR ANYWHERE
FROM TWENTY FIVE TO FORTY YEARS
ALL OF YEAH ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
THAT VOTERS DESERVE TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE VOTING ON I ASK FOR NOVA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS -- I'VE GOT MISTER
MULLIN MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL I KNOW YOU.
HAVE HAD EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER
OBERNOLTE AND KNOW THAT YOU WILL
HAVE A REAL PASSION FOR THIS
ISSUE ROUND TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE.
SO.
AND YOU AND I WERE EXCHANGING
INFORMATION LAST NIGHT AS A
MATTER OF FACT BUT FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
YOU'RE ADVOCATING.
FOR LANGUAGE THAT SAYS THIS
MEASURE AFFECTS TAX RATES SEE
VOTER GUIDE FOR INFORMATION AND
WE'VE LANDED ON SEE VOTER GUIDE
FOR TAX RATE INFORMATION.
I THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE.
APPROXIMATION OF WHAT YOU'RE
ADVOCATING FOR MY QUESTION IS
AROUND.
THE SUGGESTION THAT A VOTER
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY SENSE THAT
THEY'RE VOTING ON A PARCEL TAX
AT ALL.
IN THAT THE DESCRIPTION HERE
WHICH TO ME LOOKS LIKE A FAIRLY
COMMON DESCRIPTION IN THE
DESCRIPTION ITSELF IT SAYS RENEW
AN EXPIRING PARCEL TAX.
I THINK JUST ON THE NATURAL
THESE FISCAL MEASURES THAT GO
BEFORE VOTERS WILL INDICATE THAT
THERE IS A TAX IN PLAY.
THAT THERE IS A QUESTION BEFORE
THE VOTERS REGARDING A NEW TAX
OR RENEWAL OF EXPIRING TAX.
BUT FOR THAT DETAILED
INFORMATION GO TO THE VOTER
GUIDE. TO ME THAT MEETS THE
THRESHOLD FOR TRANSPARENCY.
AND DISCLOSURE THAT A VOTER IS
IN FACT VOTING ON A TAX AND IF
THEY WANT DETAILED INFORMATION
TO GO TO THE VOTER GUIDE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS I THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE -- AMENDMENT -- THAT
THE AUTHOR IS WILLING TO TAKE IN
WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
MR VERNAL TO SUGGESTION THIS
MEASURE AFFECTS TAX RATES.
WHY WAS UNACCEPTABLE?
SO IT MAY OR MAY NOT BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE RENEWING AN
EXISTING PARCEL TAX AND NOT
INCREASING AND MIGHT BE EXACTLY
THE SAME OR COULD EVEN BE LOWER --
YOU'RE NOT A IT'S NOT A FACTOR
BUT WELL IT'S LOWERING YES THAT
AFFECTS OF BUT IF YOU'RE JUST
RENEWING AN EXISTING ONE NOT
CHANGE YET IT DOESN'T AFFECTED.
IN ADDITION FOR BONDS.
DIFFERENT CITIES HAVE DIFFERENT
POLICIES FOR EXAMPLE -- IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE A BINDING
POLICY THAT WE DO NOT ISSUE.
NEW EVEN IF VOTERS COMMEMORATIVE
VOTERS APPROVE A BOND.
THOSE BONDS DON'T EVER HAVE TO
BE ISSUED RIGHT OF DID THE VOTER
APPROVAL SIMPLY AUTHORIZES THE
SALE OF THE BONDS AND THE BONDS
ARE NEVER SOLD WHICH
OCCASIONALLY DOES HAPPEN.
THAN NOT BEEN THERE'S NO IMPACT
ON ANYTHING SO SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE A BOND IT'S AUTHORIZED AND
THEN EITHER IT'S ONLY PARTIALLY
SOLD OR NOT SOLD AT ALL.
AND SOMETIMES I'LL EXAMINE CISCO
WE HAVE A POLICY THAT WE DO NOT
SELL AND ISSUE A NEW BOND.
UNLESS WE ARE RETIRING AND
EQUIVALENT BOND -- AND SO IT
DOES NOT AFFECT PEOPLE'S TAX
RATES AT ALL IN THE TO POLICY
THE CITY I I'M I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE ARE OTHER CITIES THAT DO
THAT I BELIEVE THERE ARE -- SO
THAT'S WHY -- USING THE WORD A
FAX IT WE THINK IS MISLEADING.
I THINK IT'S BETTER TO TO SAY
FOR TAX INFORMATION AND MAKES IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THE TAX
APPLIES HERE -- TAX INFORMATION
SEE THE VOTER HANDBOOK AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT WILL NOT
EVERYONE GOES AND READ THE VOTER
HANDBOOK BUT THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE VOTER HABITATS WE PUT THE
TAXED.
OF OF BALLOT MEASURES WE PUT ALL
SORTS OF INFORMATION IN THERE SO
THE PEOPLE CAN ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION WE CAN'T FORCE
PEOPLE. TO DO IT BUT BUT THEY
SAY THAT BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO READ THE HANDBOOK.
WE SHOULD THEREFORE BE PUTTING
ALL THIS INFORMATION IN THE
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS IN EITHER
CREATE AN OUTRAGEOUS SITUATION
LIKE THIS OR A SITUATION WHERE
YOU'RE JUST MAKING AN EXCEPTION
HARD TO EVEN DESCRIBE A SIMPLE
MEASURE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S A
SOLUTION I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
ACCOMMODATION THE METAL.
THANK YOU SENATE I'M AS MR OVER
MULTI I'M JUST.
I'M JUST CURIOUS YOU KNOW WHEN
IT COMES -- TO WHEN MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER MALL AND JUST SAID SEEMS
LIKE THE COMPROMISE IS WORKED
OUT BY THE CHAIR IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS RELATIVELY CLOSE TO
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR SEE VOTER
GUIDE FOR TAX RATE INFORMATION.
AGAIN JUST GOING TO LOVE IT WHY
IS THAT NOT SUFFICIENT WHY DOES
IT HAVE TO INCREASE WISE HAVE TO
BE AFFECTS WHAT YOU KNOW WHY IT
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT ISN'T
CLEAR ENOUGH FOR VOTERS. TO
REASONABLY DISCERN THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME TYPE OF IMPACT --
TO A TAX RATE OR TO TAXES BY BY
THE PASSAGE OF THAT THAT OF THAT
MEASURE.
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT THE VOTER RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S GOOD AND BAD IN THE
PROPOSITION.
THE GOOD IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ISSUE BONDS AND DO ALL OF THIS
GOOD STUFF BUILT A FIRE STATION
OR WHATEVER IT IS AND THE BAD IS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
INCREASE PROPERTY TAXES TO DO IT.
SO IF YOU JUST SAY SEE VOTER
GUIDE FOR TAX RATE INFORMATION
DOESN'T CONVEY THE IMPRESSION
THAT THERE IS A PRICE TO BE PAID --
SO THAT'S WHY I DON'T THINK IT'S
UNREASONABLE TO SAY AFFECTS TAX
RATES.
AND OF THE AUTHORED I HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS OF MY
RESPONSE TO THE CRITICISM OF
WELL SOME OF THEM DON'T.
WAS WILL FIND THAT'S GREAT LET'S
JUST PUT WILL SPLIT IT WILL SAY
IF IT AFFECTS TAX RATE YOU SAY
THIS MEASURE AFFECTS TAX RATES
SEE VOTER GUIDE.
AND IF IT DOESN'T YOU JUST SAFE
YOU SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR
INFORMATION HE'S EASILY SOLVED
BUT THAT WAS ACCEPTABLE EITHER.
AND AND JUST SO FOLKS KNOW I TRY
TO WORK WITH -- MISTER WHEN ALL
THE ON THIS -- IS MEASURE IT MAY
AFFECT TAX RATES SEE VOTER GUIDE
FOR INFORMATION AND AND THAT WAS.
REJECTED -- SO WE WE TRIED ALSO
SPEAK MORE TO THAT AT THE END --
BUT THIS IS THE THE FINAL RESULT
THAT WE ENDED UP AT WELL I I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU TO
INVESTIGATION AND OTHERS A LOT
OF RESPECT BETWEEN YOU TWO AND
AS A LOT OF RESPECT FROM THE
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THE BOTH OF YOU -- YOU KNOW I I
CITY WHERE -- LIVE COUNSEL AT
THAT MAJORITY REPUBLICAN THREE
REPUBLICANS TO DEMOCRATS AND
THEY CAME TO ME VERY WORRIED --
THIS LAST YEAR THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE THE VOTES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED.
TO PASS A MEASURE TO ALLOW THEM
TO BE TO TO BUILD A NEW LIBRARY.
ALSO THE AFTER MY SUPPORTERS I
SUPPORTED IT AND YOU KNOW DID
WHATEVER WE COULD TO TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE BUT
ULTIMATELY -- WHILE IT WAS
SEEMINGLY PROMISING ON ELECTION
NIGHT THE THE MEASURE ENDED UP
FAILING -- TO REACH THE
THRESHOLD AND NEEDED TO REACH
OUT TO GET THE SUPPORT -- TO
BUILD THE NEW LIBRARY -- INSEL.
I I DO I DO FIND THAT ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO A LOCAL ISSUE
THAT THESE.
THE VERBIAGE AND WHAT IS THERE
AND WHAT IS NOT THERE REALLY
TENS OF FACT AND IMPACT THE
OUTCOME AND WE'RE ALL BUSY WE
ALL OF A LOT OF THINGS TO DO --
I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR
INFORMATION TO BE THERE BUT
INFORMATION IS BE CLEAR NEEDS TO
BE CONCISE BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE
JUST GOING.
TO REALLY KINDA HIT REAL QUICK
AND MAKE A DECISION RIGHT THEN
AND THERE IS THIS WHAT I WANT IS
THIS WHEN I'M WILLING TO TO PAY
FOR IT -- AS LONG AS IT'S
REASONABLY CLEAR THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME TYPE OF AN IMPACT --
WHEN IT COMES TO TAX RATES I
THINK IT'S?
IT'S IMPORTANT I TO CLEAN THAT
UP AS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
WHILE PROVIDING THE INFORMATION
SO THAT PEOPLE.
IF THEY ARE INTERESTED CAN
UNDERSTAND HEY THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS WHAT I'M IN FOR AND THIS IS
HOW IT'S GONNA SPECIFICALLY
IMPACT ME.
YOU KNOW I I KNOW YOU KIND OF
QUALIFIED TAX IS A BAD THING.
YOU KNOW IF I COULD PAY TWENTY
MORE DOLLARS -- YOU KNOW A MONTH
TO BUILD A NEW LIBRARY OR CURE
CANCER WHATEVER IT IS I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO DO THAT -- AND I
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THAT'S
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
ALL ON US TO PAY FOR THE TYPE OF
SOCIETY THAT WE WANT TO LIVE IN.
BUT IT SEEMS AT THIS POINT THAT.
IT'S REASONABLE BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER GOT A LOT OF A LOT OF
PRECIADO -- FOR WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND HOW WE'RE
GOING ABOUT IT AND I AND I THINK
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO LOOK AT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT EXAMPLES -- BUT IF
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE IN
A SOMETHING WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES.
I HAVE A MOTION AS FOR ME THE
SECOND.
I HAVE A SECOND -- CENTER WOULD
YOU LIKE A CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND BECAUSE I PROCEEDED THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION ON ON
THIS ISSUE IT -- I DO JUST WANT
A TWO THINGS FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE THE AUTHOR AND I'VE
ALREADY COMMITTED WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE. TO TO TO TALK AND SEE --
IF THERE IS A AWAY BUT I THINK
ON A CAT CAN NEVER GUARANTEE
RESULTS -- BUT I WILL SAY THAT
THE THE CHAIR.
PUSH US OUT OF OUR COMFORT ZONE.
RIGHT AND THAT MEASURE THE
TERRIBLE ATTACHED -- WE WERE
INITIALLY VERY RESISTANT TO WHAT
THE GENERAL MOTORING.
HI CAN ATTEST AND THE CHECK.
AND FOR THE CHAIR AND I WE WE
WENT BACK AND FORTH AND WHAT I
THINK WE CAME TO A GOOD.
COMPROMISE AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND BY ONE OF THOSE A REFERENCE
MADE TO SPECIAL INTERESTS AND I
DON'T AS MUCH AS I LOVE THAT AND
I'VE I'VE HAD MY DISAGREEMENTS
WITH THOUGHT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING.
TIME TO TIME -- BUT BUT BUT BUT
OUR CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
I WOULD NOT DO THEM A SPECIAL
INTERESTS THESE ARE.
PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT WE A LOCKED
TO EDUCATE OUR KIDS.
TO NOT PROVIDE WATER AND SEWER
SERVICES TO KEEP THE LIBRARIES
OPEN AND KEEP THE FIRE STATIONS
OPEN -- AND SO I THINK THEY ARE
PART OF OUR PUBLIC FAMILY AND I
THINK THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
RAISE REVENUE AND IT'S ALREADY
HARD ENOUGH.
BOB WE SHOULDN'T BE MAKING IT
HARDER -- AND I RESPECT WESTERN
AGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND AND
THANK YOU TO TO THE FOLKS IN
FAVOR THE FOLKS IN SUPPORT.
OF THE CONVERSATION ALSO FROM
COLLEAGUES WHEN -- I HEARD ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I SPOKE WITH BOTH
CENTER WIENER AND AND SOME
NUMBER ONE ON THE AND ENCOURAGE
THEM. TO TRY TO WORK OUT A
COMPROMISE AND AND REALLY HOPE
THAT THEY WOULD -- AND THEN THEY
CAME TO ME A COUPLE OF DAYS SO
CLOSE.
AND THEY CAME TO ME A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO AND SAID WE JUST CAN'T
GET THERE -- AND I KNEW THEN
THAT I'D HAVE TO GUIDE GET MORE
INVOLVED AND AND END UP COMING
TO A RESULT THAT DISAPPOINTED
EVERYBODY -- AND I THINK I'VE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
BUT I THINK I THINK IT'S IT'S
THE RIGHT PLACE FOR THIS BILL --
YOU KNOW.
I HAVE SO MUCH AFFINITY FOR THE
EFFORT THAT GOES INTO PASSING
PARCEL TAXES AND SCHOOL BONDS
WERE THE FIRST THINGS I DID AT
THE LOCAL LEVELS VOLUNTEER.
AND TWO THOUSAND TEN ON A LOCAL
PARCEL TAX OF THE YARD SIGN GUY
THAT WAS THAT WAS WHAT I WAS IN
CHARGE OF WHEN THEY WENT BACK TO
RENEW THAT PARCEL TAX I WAS THEN
ON THE CITY COUNCIL -- AND I CAN
ENDORSE IT AND MAYBE WAS ON THE
BALLOT -- AS A SIGNATORY I CAN'T
RECALL AND THEN A COUPLE YEARS
LATER WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
THEY CAME TO ME AND ASK FOR MY
HELP IN SUPPORTING THE BOND
MEASURE -- AND I'VE SEEN THE
ENDLESS HOURS FROM VOLUNTEERS IN
THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE TRYING TO
IMPROVE THEIR COMMUNITY FOR
THEIR KIDS FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
FOR THE OTHER NEIGHBORS -- AND
HOW DIFFICULT THAT IS WITH A LOT
OF THESE EFFORTS WITH THE TWO
THIRDS THRESHOLD THAT I THINK IS
UNNECESSARILY HIGH -- AND THAT I
FULLY SUPPORT LOWERING -- AND I
FULLY SUPPORT A CA ONE THAT I
KNOW HAS BEEN INTRODUCED TO DO
THAT -- BUT WHILE THE THE THE
THRESHOLD IS.
UNNECESSARILY HIGH AND ALLOWS A
STRONG MINORITY TO DEFEAT THE
WILL OF A VERY STRONG MAJORITY.
I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE ON THE BALLOT AND AND THE
FACT THAT -- PROVIDING VOTERS
WITH WITH USEFUL AND TRANSPARENT
ACCURATE INFORMATION IN THE VERY
LIMITED SPACE THAT IS AVAILABLE
IS INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING -- AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT THE INFORMATION.
IS INCLUDED IN THE VOTER GUIDE
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT TAKES A REMARKABLY
COMPLICATED SITUATION.
IT SAYS IT'S FULLY FLUSH THAT
OUT IN THE VOTER GUIDE -- AND
LET'S PROVIDE SOME OF THE HIGH
LEVEL INFORMATION IN THE SEVENTY
FIVE WORDS ON THE BALLOT THE
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURESTHAT WILL
APPEAR IN THE VOTER GUIDE UNDER
THIS BILL PROVIDE USEFUL AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION -- SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT TO ENSURE THAT VOTERS
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE IS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TAX IMPLEMENT IMPLICATIONS.
OF TAX AND BOND MEASURES IN THE
VOTER GUIDE -- WITH THAT
AMENDMENT IN THE TECHNICAL
MOMENT OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDD AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON HELLO.
LOW NOT VOTING MAYES.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THAT BILL IS OUT -- WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOUNG UNDERTAKEN
YOU'LL REMEMBER THANK YOU
EVERYONE ELSE.
CENTER MOVING ON YOUR NEXT BILL
SB -- TWO EIGHTY EIGHT I NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIVE YEAH
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY CENTER.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- AND THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL -- AND WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH I JUST WANNA
NUMERATOR THERE ARE THE MORE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS CONTAIN THE
ANALYSIS AND WE ACCEPT THOSE --
IN ADDITION -- YEAH -- YOU AND I
WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT ON A
RESTRUCTURING OF THE BILL
INCLUDING SOME INTENT LANGUAGE
TO THAT WE CAN REFINE -- THE
BILL OVER THE COMING MONTHS THEM
WILL WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT I JUST WANT --
TO WITH THIS YEAR'S MISSIONS AS
READ PLACE BECAUSE IT'S RATHER
BRIEF YEAH SO THE BILL WILL BE
RESTRUCTURED TO READ AS FOLLOWS
SECTION.
ONE IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT LEGISLATION
TO PERMIT A PERSON WHO IS NOT A
UNITED STATES CITIZEN. TO BE
ELECTED IN THE SERVICE A MEMBER
OF A COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY COMMA IF
PERMITTED BY THE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE.
SECTION -- TWO READS SECTION
SEVENTY TWO TEN IS ADDED TO
ELECTIONS CODE TO READ --
NOTWITHSTANDING SECTION SEVEN
TWO OH NINE A PERSON WHO IS NOT
REGISTERED AS AFFILIATED WITH
THIS PARTY IS ELIGIBLE FOR
APPOINTMENT TO A COMMITTEE OF
SUCH AN APPOINTMENT AS PERMITTED
BY THE BY LAWS OF THE COMMITTEE --
AND THAT FIRST SECTION AGAIN IS
INTENT LANGUAGE AND WILL BE
WORKING TOGETHER TO TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ADDRESSING ALL THE
SPECIFIC DETAILS TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE'RE DOING THIS IN EXACTLY THE
RIGHT WAY AND I CAN APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE WORKING WITH US
AND WE DO ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT
IN ADDITION TO THE MOMENT STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS GREAT THANKS.
HUN SO -- MY COLLEAGUES I THIS --
THE GOAL OF SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
IS TO ENSURE THAT ARE DREAMERS
AND OTHER IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ABLE TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE.
IN OUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ARE WE ARE IN A A PARTY -- THAT
HAS EMBRACED OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES HAS ENGAGE OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES -- AT OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ARE
ALREADY DEEPLY INVOLVED I IN THE
WORK OF OUR PARTY.
BUT THEY CAN NOT SERVED US SERVE
IN LEADERSHIP ROLES AND WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST TO HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE SPEAKING FOR THEM
BUT TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES AND TO BE ABLE TO
LEAD.
A AND I THIS ISSUE WHICH IS OUR
WE KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS INDICATED --
THAT LATER THIS YEAR IT WILL BE
TAKING UP RULE CHANGES IN TERMS
OF ALLOWING -- IT NON CITIZENS
TO SERVE AS DELEGATES OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
IS ALREADY UNDER DISCUSSION AND
IN PROCESS -- AND I BELIEVE IT
MAY BE TAKEN UP AT THE BOARD
MEETING -- IN AUGUST.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WILL THAT THERE -- FOR
POTENTIALLY BE CHANGING ITS OWN
RULES.
I IN ORDER FOR DOT TO APPLY AT
THE COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE
LEVEL ON A REVISION TO THE
ELECTIONS CODE.
IS REQUIRED BECAUSE ELECTION
CODE CURRENTLY ON REQUIRED THAT
A PERSON BE REGISTERED TO VOTE
IN ORDER TO SERVE ON A COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN THIS BILL.
WILL ALLOW CENTRAL COMMITTEE IF
THEY CHOOSE IN THIS OP FORCE
THEM TO DO IT BUT IF THEY CHOOSE.
TO ALLOW NON CITIZENS --
INCLUDING DREAMERS TO RUN FOR
CENTRAL COMMITTEE OR TO BE
APPOINTED -- TO SERVICE I THIS
ISSUE -- IS ACTUALLY QUITE
CURRENT -- IN SAN FRANCISCO WERE
EARLIER THIS YEAR -- THE CHAIR
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE THEY'VE
ACCOMPLISHED APPOINTED SERWIS
WHO SAW WHO IS SITTING.
WITH ME TODAY -- WHO IS A
DREAMER -- POINTED HER -- TO
FILL A VACANCY -- CREATED BY
RESIGNATION ON THE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE.
SHE IS SERVING AND DOING A GREAT
JOB ON OUR CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
SHE CANNOT RUN FOR REELECTION.
AND AND AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- IMMIGRANTS TWO
ALREADY PLAY SUCH A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ARE ABLE TO ACTUALLY SERVE --
AND LEAD -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE ALWAYS SENSITIVITIES
AROUND THESE ISSUES BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR.
THAT -- WE ALREADY HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE CITIES -- I'M
NOT SAN FRANCISCO DOES IT WITH
RESPECT TO SCHOOL BOARD -- AND
THERE ARE OTHER CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY THAT HAVE DONE IT
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE
AUTHORIZED.
NON CITIZENS WHO ARE RESIDENTS
OF THAT CITY TO VOTE IN LOCAL
ELECTIONS.
AND THEY CREATE SYSTEMS WHERE --
IN A NON CITIZEN WHO IS A
RESIDENT CASH AND BY AFFIDAVIT --
CONFIRM THAT THEY ARE RESIDENT
WHERE THEY LIVE AND THEY'RE
THERE FOR ELIGIBLE A TO VOTE SO
IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED. TO ALLOW
NON CITIZENS TO PARTICIPATE
FORMALLY IN OUR POLITICAL
PROCESS AND HERE WE'RE NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT A GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND THE QUESTION IS SHOULD THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BE ABLE TO MAKE
ITS OWN DECISION.
ABOUT WHETHER OR WHETHER WHETHER
OR NOT. TO ALLOW.
IMMIGRANTS. TO PARTICIPATE AT
THIS LEVEL I THINK THEY SHOULD I
THINK WE SHOULD GIVE THE PART OF
THE FLEXIBILITY WE ARE NOT
FORCING THE PARTY TO DO ANYTHING --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE -- WITH ME HERE
TESTIFIED TODAY ARE AS A MENTION
SERVICE TO SO -- WHO IS -- WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO LATINO
DEMOCRATIC CLUB ADDED APPOINTED
MEMBER CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND THE
SAID -- SERRANO OF YOUNG LATINOS
A SPIRE.
THANK YOU PLEASE [inaudible]
CLOSE WINDOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN OF THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
I'M SARAH SUSANNAH I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
LATINO DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
I AM ALSO AN APPOINT A MEMBER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO CENTRAL
COMMITTEE -- YOU KNOW I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DREAMERS AND ELEVEN
MILLION -- NON CITIZENS ARE WHO
ARE AMERICAN IN NEVER WAY EXCEPT
DOCUMENTATION -- I'M GRATEFUL
AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WILL.
SERVE AS A PLATFORM TO UP LIFT
THE VOICES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
I'M A PROUD CALIFORNIA MYSELF
AND THE BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR
BOTH ELECTION AN APPOINTMENT OF
NON CITIZENS.
AYE IMMIGRATED TO THIS COUNTRY
WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL HERE COLLEGE
AND NOW I HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE.
I'M READY TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ECONOMY AND CREATE JOBS AND
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
ABLE TO OVERCOME FINANCIAL
BARRIERS.
AS I DREAM OF THE DREAMER MYSELF
RAISED BY A SINGLE MOTHER I HOPE
HAD TO OVERCOME MANY BARRIERS.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA AND AS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER -- IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS I STRONGLY BELIEVE
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE -- TO REPRESENT
THEMSELVES IN ADVOCATE FOR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY IN SHAPE THE
PLATFORM THAT WILL ENHANCE
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT.
CALIFORNIANS ON CITIZENS OUR
POPULATIONS MORE THAN -- FIVE
MILLION OF THE THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS STRONGER WHEN WE
UTILIZE THE TALENTS OF ALL OUR
RESIDENTS AND AS A RESULT OF MY
ACTIVE PARTICIPATION.
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS I HAVE
BOTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
AND YOU KNOW EDUCATED MEMBERS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING AND
REGISTER TO VOTE AND CONTRIBUTE
YOUR DEMOCRACY.
ACCORDING TO THE PEW RESEARCH
THERE'S GOING TO BE MILLION OF
YOUNG LATINOS TURNING EIGHTEEN
EVERY YEAR FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS SO THERE WILL BE THE ONE
VOTING FOR THE NEXT
REPRESENTATIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
OF IMMIGRANT LEADERS PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN BUILDING
THRIVING COMMUNITIES SO.
I'M HERE. TO EXPRESS MY FULL
SUPPORT AND THIS BILL HAS A
COMMUNITY SUPPORT INCLUDING
CHICANO LATINO CAUCUS A SAN
FRANCISCO LATINO DEMOCRATIC CLUB
SAN FRANCISCO -- DEMOCRATIC
PARTY A C. I. P. C. AND OTHER
COMMITTEE ADVOCATES AND LABOR
PLEASE READ -- SO I RESPECTFULLY
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB TWO EIGHTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING TO REMEMBER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS A SET OF SOLANO PRESIDENT AND
CO FOUNDER AGAIN MEDINA SPIRE.
AND NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO EMPOWER GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ADVOCATE IN
FAVOR OF SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT AS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF MY COMMUNITY AND
VOTING CITIZEN I BELIEVE IT'S
OUR DUTY TO PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATION FOR EVERYONE.
AS A FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT I HAVE
FOUND MY PASSION AND COMMUNITY
ADVOCACY.
HOWEVER HAS BEEN AN UP HILL UP
HILL BATTLE TO FIND APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATION.
THAT ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDS MY
STRUGGLE AND MY NEEDS AS WELL AS
A STRUGGLE IN THE NEEDS OF
MEMBERS OF MY ORGANIZATION AND
THE STRUGGLE IN THE NEEDS OF
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THIS WILL
EMPOWER AND UPLIFT THE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND SEVEN EXAMPLE OF AN ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION IN LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN TODAY SPEAKING MY
CAPACITY AS THE RESOLUTIONS
CHAIR OF THE LATINO CHICANO
CAUCUS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AS WELL AS A CO LEAD CHAIR.
OF THE LEGISLATION COMMITTEE OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
URGING AN AYE VOTE ON THE
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THANKS THANK
YOU.
ALVIN WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT SB TO EAT.
THANK YOU.
OP ED HERNANDEZ -- ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO VOTER I'M HERE MY
PERSONAL CAPACITY I IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ROGUES HOW AWESOME SAN FRANCISCO
NOT A VOTER BECAUSE I'M A NON
CITIZEN PERMANENT RESIDENT AND
ARE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CITY WHEREVER -- PARTY HASN'T
TAKEN A POSITION BUT WE SUPPORT
RASHTRA SAY I SUPPORT THE BILL
OF AN INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY.
HAD.
UNDOCUMENTED -- GETTING FROM THE
VATICAN NAY IN THE NINETIES
BEFORE WAS FORCED BY THE STATE.
TO TAKE HIM OFF AND FELL I DON'T
KNOW WHY WERE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE BILL BUT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAPTER TO KIA.
ADVOCATE OF VARIOUS COALITIONS
IN GROUPS BUT CALIFORNIA IS MADE
UP OF IMMIGRANTS SO PLEASE THIS
IS IMPORTANT TO BE COUNTED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I NEED TO KNOW WHEN THIS IS IN
SUPPORT.
SING NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR FREE TO COME ON
UP TO THE DESK IF YOU WANT
.
MY NAME IS SUCKLING BRITAIN I
WITH THE ALEXIAN INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
OF JUST HANDED A BRIEF POSITION
PAPER.
OF BASICALLY OUR FOCUS IS THE OF
NON CITIZEN SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED
TO ASSIMILATE. TO WORK ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS AND STRIVE FOR
CITIZENSHIP.
OF BEFORE THEY BEFORE THEY VOTE
OF THE BY LAWS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RIGHT NOW CLEARLY STATE.
THAT MEMBERS OF THE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE MUST BE REGISTERED TO
VOTE.
A WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
NON CITIZENS CANNOT LEGALLY BE
REGISTERED TO VOTE.
AND THUS CANNOT BE PERMITTED TO
HOLD OFFICE.
IN IN THAT COMMITTEE AND NO
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
CAN OVERTURN A CONSTITUTIONAL
MANDATE.
ANOTHER THING HAVING NON
CITIZENS ON ELECTED COMMITTEES.
OF IS VERY IS THE VERY
DEFINITION OF FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE OR NON NON CITIZENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THREE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT A
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTION SECONDS
[inaudible]
MISTER MESS.
YEAH I'M IT SEEMS WEIRD -- BUT
WE HAVE TO EVEN -- BUT I HAVE
LEGISLATION IN REGARDS TO THIS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE -- ANYBODY I'M
SERVE ON THE COMMITTEE WHY WHY
NOT -- AND I GUESS THAT THE UP
BUTTON JUST LEARNED THIS A
MOMENT AGO I GUESS THERE'S A WE
HAVE DEMOCRATIC CODE SECTION IN
A REPUBLICAN THAT CODE SECTION
WHICH SEEMS VERY ODD TO ME
BECAUSE OF THE PARTIES AS SHOULD
BE.
DOWN THERE THEIR OWN ENTITIES --
AND ESTABLISH THEIR THEIR OWN
RULES I'M TO SUPPORT THIS --
TODAY -- JUST BECAUSE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS IT THIS
BILL TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
IT IS NO QUESTIONS CONTACT WEBER.
JUST OUT SO THE THE BILL NOW IS
JUST THE STREETS HERE THIS
INTENT L<c.cyan>G CORRECT -- AND</c>
THERE THERE IS LANGUAGE IN THERE
TO ALLOW APPOINTMENT.
I SAW THE THE POINT IS HERE YES
OF APPOINTMENTS THAT IS
STATUTORY AND THEN THEY'LL TEN
LANGUAGE TO DO SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT.
THERE'S SOME COMPLICATED DETAILS
THEN YOU'D BE WORKED OUT OKAY SO
BASICALLY THIS DOES IS GO TO THE
FLOOR THIS IS JUST INTENT LÏNG
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS THIS WILL
GO TO THE FLOOR BUT CENTER IN
PLACE.
YEAH IT THE MOTION THE MOTION I
BELIEVE IS TO THE FLOOR IT'S NOT
A AND IS NO FISCAL IMPACT BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE TAKING IT
UP UNTIL WE WORK EVERYTHING OUT
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
SO -- SO IT'LL BE AWHILE BEFORE
IT ACTUALLY WOULD BE THE END OF
THE COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT IS OUR INTENT THEIR
INTENTION OUR INTENTION OKAY
YEAH BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED
AND YOUNG HAS POINTED UP IS A
LOT OF AND WE HAD.
A CONVERSATION LAST NIGHT IS A
LOT OF CONFUSING ELEMENTS OF IT --
I DON'T SEEM LIKE IF WE CAN IF
THE DEMS DO THE REPUBLICANS
OUGHT TO DO IT LIKE LAST -- BUT
IS THAT JUST AN AWFUL LOT OF
ISSUESABOUT MEMBERSHIP ON
COMMITTEES AND DELEGATES IN
VOTING FOR NOMINEES AND
PRESIDENTS AND ALL THOSE OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN WHEN
YOU ON THE CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
AND YOUR DELEGATE AND SO -- AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
BECAUSE WE JUST WENT THROUGH
THIS WHOLE THING WITH THE
NETWORK.
THE RUSSIANS SHOULD BE INVOLVED
IN OUR LOCATIONS YES AND WE'VE
HAD CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
SENEGAL FROM OUTSIDE PEOPLE AND
IT JUST GETS REAL COMPLICATED
AND SO I I I WOULD LIKE SOME
CLARITY ON ALL OF THOSE THINGS
BECAUSE THEY BEGIN TO SOME OUT
OF THE CONFLICT WITH THE VALUES.
THE PEOPLE SAY THEY HAVEN'T ONE
LEVEL BUT NOT AT THE NOT THE
LEVEL SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT THAT WOULD BE IN.
FACT WE SHOULD THAT THING OUT
WEBER.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE DID I HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND I BELIEVE INTENT
LANGUAGES WITH EMOTION THE AND
THAT'S THE INTENT LANGUAGE PLUS
THE THE OTHER THE OTHER BIT YEAH.
SO SECOND I'M GONNA MOTION --
AND A SECOND -- THANK YOU TO THE
CENTER -- FOR BRING THE BILL FOR
IN MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR THEIR
COMMENTS IF WE'RE GOING TO AMEND
STATE LAW TO ALLOW PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT U. S. CITIZENS TO RUN
FOR DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE --
ON MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL IS
WORKABLE FOR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
AND COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEES
AND DOES NOT CREATE UNACCEPTABLE
RISKS FOR CANDIDATES.
WHO MIGHT RUN FOR CENTRAL
COMMITTEE IF THE LAW IS CHANGED
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE?
TO ARRIVE AND THEM AND SO THIS
BILL THAT ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS -- AND
I ANTICIPATE THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS TO COME UP
WITH A WORKABLE PROCESS.
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
U. S. CITIZENS TO RUN FOR COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT THE
OPPOSITION.
YOU SAID WILL PEOPLE SHOULD
ASSIMILATE AND VOLUNTEER IT'S A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP AND THESE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW THE THE
WITNESSES.
HAVE BEEN VOLUNTEERING -- AT BUT
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP AND THAT'S A PROBLEM
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT WE DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER BUT WE DO HAVE
CONTROL OVER THIS -- AND AND I
THINK THAT FOLKS THAT HAVE GONE
INVOLVED AND YOU CAN'T JUST WALK
ONTO A CENTRAL COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE TO VOLUNTEER FIRST YES ARM
PEOPLE'S TRUST YOU HAVE TO YOU
KNOW BE IN THE TRENCHES -- AND
SO I I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
TIME TO WORK OUT THE DETAILS
WHICH IS WHAT WE ACCOMPLISHED IN
THE BILL TODAY -- LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR ON THIS AND WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING I I RECOMMEND
SUPPORT THE BILL.
MA'AM SECONDARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BERMAN HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON I KNOW.
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER HI WEBER AVE.
THAT IS OUT WITH -- FOR VOTES
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLER.
THANK YOU.
IN THE MIDDLE.
I SEE SENATOR STERN.
IN THE AUDIENCE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SB [inaudible]
SIX THIRTY SIX YEAH.
MORNING MORNING SENATOR.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANKS SIR
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
IN THIS DAY AND AGE IT'S HARDER
AND HARDER TO CUT THROUGH THE
NOISE IN OUR POLITICS.
WHEN YOU ARRIVE AT THAT BALLOT
BOX?
THE HOPE IS YOU'VE DONE ALL YOUR
HOMEWORK -- WHAT HOMEWORK IN
TALES NOWADAYS ON TWITTER OR
FACEBOOK CORD TELEVISION -- IS
TRICKY AND PART OF THE INTENT OF
THIS MEASURE IS [inaudible]
TO BRING USEFUL BUT CONSOLIDATED
INFORMATION OF VOTERS TO HELP
THEM MAKE DECISIONS -- I THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S A HEALTHY
DEBATE TO BE HAD ABOUT.
WHAT IS THATKIND OF SIGNAL YOU
NEED AT THE BALLOT BOX TO REALLY
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT A BALLOT
INITIATIVE COMING YOUR WAY?
AND WE THINK THE PREMISE THIS
BILL IS WHO'S BEHIND THAT
MEASURE SAYS A LOT ABOUT.
THE CONTENT AND QUALITY OF THAT
BUT YOU HERE TODAY ABOUT SOME
ISSUES AROUND MECHANICS AND AND
COST STORYLINES IN SORT OF THE
BALLOT BEING TOO CONFUSING.
AND THAT THINGS BELONGING TO
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE.
I DON'T WANT -- TO CASTIGATE.
THE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE IS
THAT UNUSUAL RESOURCE BUT IT WAS
OVER A HUNDRED PAGES THE LAST
ELECTIONS LIKE WE ABOUT TWELVE
INITIATIVE.
AND THERE THE SUPER DILIGENT
VOTERS OUT THERE WHO WHO REVIEW
IT -- BUT THERE ARE MANY OF US
WHO LOOK FOR SHORT CUTS AND WHO
SIMPLY DIDN'T DO ALL THAT
HOMEWORK AND SHOP I DON'T ON
ELECTION DAY AND WANT TO CAST
THEIR VOTE.
OR EVEN IT VOTE BY MAIL THEY
JUST PICK UP ABOUT THEY WANT TO
WORK THROUGH IT SO THE GOAL HERE
IS TO ON THAT BALLOT. TO SEE
BELOW WHATEVER THE INITIATIVE IS
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE VOTING ON
WHO THE TOP THREE SUPPORTERS AND
OPPONENTS ARE.
I WE THINK THIS GIVES ROOM --
FOR ALL KINDS OF INTERESTS RIGHT
LEFT MIDDLE NOT EVEN ON THE
SPECTRUM -- BUT WE THINK THAT
THIS IS USEFUL INFORMATION FOR
VOTERS AND THAT IT'LL HOPEFULLY
EMPOWER PEOPLE THE BALLOT BOX
MORE AND LESS SO. TO THE IMPACT
OF THE NOISE OUT THERE IN OUR
POLITICS THESE DAYS -- HAPPEN
ANSWER QUESTIONS IN DIGGING
FURTHER I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS AND I II'M
I'M HOPING THE STATE CULTURE
HERE FROM OUR ELECTION OFFICIALS
BECAUSE I THINK WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A PRETTY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION SO.
WITH THAT'LL JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AT THE CENTER YEAH.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT'S
THAT TRENT LYING -- PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA MONEY CAMPAIGN PROUD
TO SPONSOR SB SIX THIRTY SIX
REALLY THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK AND AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS --
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK.
AS WE WORKED ON THE THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT --
BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW THE MOST ARE WHO IS
BEHIND INITIATIVES.
WHO'S WHO'S PAYING FOR
INITIATIVES AND PEOPLE ALSO
WON'T WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
SUPPORTING AND OPPOSING
INITIATIVES WITH THE DISCLOSE
ACT ON POLITICAL ADS WE CAN'T
REQUIRE THEM TO PUT.
HERE'S YOUR AT IT NOW YOU HAVE
TO LIST YOUR OPPONENTS ABOUT
THAT WOULD NOT BE A RECALL
REASONABLE THING TO DO FOR
POLITICAL ADS.
BUT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT WE DO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION AND THE
BALLOT PAMPHLET.
AND WE COULD PROVIDE IT ON THE
BALLOT ITSELF THE BALLOT ITSELF
IT IS CURRENTLY THE SEVENTY FIVE
WORDS ON THE BALLOT IS A U.
USEFUL CONDENSED SUMMARY.
OF JUST THE THE THAT THREE OR
FOUR PAGE -- OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS
AND THEN THE ONE OR TWO PAGE
FISCAL IMPACT STATE A STATEMENT
BUT IT'S A VERY VERY CONDENSER
SUMMARY THAT REALLY DOESN'T GIVE
VOTERS JUST KIND OF GIVES.
A REMINDER PERHAPS OB BUT THE
BALLOT BUT ALSO HAS THE OTHER
CRUCIAL INFORMATION OF THOSE
ARGUMENTS FOR AND AGAINST AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY -- WHO IS
SIGNING THEM PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE
TRUST ONE WAY OR THE OTHER SO WE
THINK THAT IS?
REALLY CRUCIAL CRUCIAL
INFORMATION FOR VOTERS.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION IN THE BILL ABOUT.
THE AMOUNT OF SPACE THAT IT
REQUIRES -- AND I CAN ACTUALLY
SEE IN THE LANGUAGE.
OF OF THE BILL THAT IT COULD BE
CLARIFIED TO TO TO TO MAKE THIS
CLEAR.
THE THE CLERKS WERE CONCERNED
THAT COULD THAT EACH OF THE FUND
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS HAD TO
BE LISTED ON SEPARATE LINES.
THAT IS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
GIVE FIFTEEN WORDS DESCRIBING
THE SUPPORTERS FIFTEEN WORDS
DESPITE DESCRIBING THE OPPONENT
SO TOTAL THIRTY TWO WORDS.
ON THE SEVENTY TWO WE MARK THAT
UP AND THAT MEANS A MODE IN MANY
CASES IT'S JUST TO ADDED LINES.
AND IN MOST AND AND THE WORST WE
EVER SEEN WAS THREE ADDED LINES
ON IN LA COUNTY A BALLOT THAT WE
ACTUALLY MOCKED UP ON SO --
INITIATIVES AN AVERAGE OF TWO OR
THREE LINES IT WOULD BE AT MOST
THIRTY ADDITIONAL LINES.
IN FACT IN MANY OF THOSE THERE'S
EXTRA BLANK SPACE AT THE END SO
THERE'S A VERY GOOD CHANCE THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE TO PRINT ANY EXTRA
PAPER AT ALL -- IN THIS CASE
WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE TO PRINT
ONE EXTRA PAGE WE THINK THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT BE.
VERY VERY USEFUL TO TO THE
PUBLIC THANK AND HAPPY TO WORK
ON THAT AND RESPONSE PRESS
RUBBER THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HER -- TIPPING SAN JOSE AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
SHELLY CAROL SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY CARRIAGE FOR BENICIA INS
FOR SAFE AND HEALTHY COMMUNITY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU AND FOLKS
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
LINE AND FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO GET BACK TO WHEREVER THEY'RE
SEAT IS.
THAT BE GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BARBARA WINDHAM AFTER TEN ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG WE ARE DUE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KATHY VARGAS DAVIS CALIFORNIA
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT IS INTERNET STOCKTON IN
STRONG SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
KIM SELLIN DAVIS IS STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DON CURRY CONSTITUENT FROM MENLO
PARK SUPPORT GREAT TO SEE A HI I
DON'T.
MIKE LEVINSON FROM DALY CITY
STRONG SUPPORT MAXIMIZE VOTER
INFORMATION THANK YOU.
PAT SACKS OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RALPH FINLEY SAID IT WAS A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMY HE HE WON IT CREEK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GARY APPEL MILL VALLEY STRONGLY
HOWARD MADDOX FROM OAKLAND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LYNETTE BUT WHEN FROM STOCKTON
CITY WHEREVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PEACE FREEDOM
PART OF CALIFORNIA WHICH SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KEPT CARRILLO SACRAMENTO.
OF SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
ACLU END INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STRONG.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
SCOTT KELTNER CONSTITUENT FROM
PALO ALTO STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU GREAT THIS IS.
HI MY NAME'S GERALD MORAN OF THE
CONSTITUENT I'M FROM PALO ALTO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PAT LANG LOS ALTOS HILLS PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RAIN HICKS SEGMENT COUNTY GREEN
PARTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JUDY JACKSON BERKELEY PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID NEWS WENGER SENATOR
BERMAN'S CONSTITUENT FROM
SUNNYVALE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CLAIRE SLOT IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROCKETS OUT FROM SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELEN AVAIL OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT EDUCATED VOTERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
NANCY NFL ALTHOUGH SUPPORT THANK
YOU GOOD TO SEE.
IN THE LATEST FROM DAVIS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVIS MET SAN FRANCISCO STRONG
ART PERSICO SAN FRANCISCO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THEN THE CAR NAY HALL OF MILL
VALLEY STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JIM DAVIDSON CONSTITUENT FROM
LOS ALTOS STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JENNIFER HAGEE SAN FRANCISCO
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY CUTHBERT'S IN OAKLAND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- RUBBER CALL
THE SECOND A GREEN PARTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
VICKI MILLER OLIVERA FRANCE AND
HAS A CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I CAROL CANCER FROM A GROVE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI KAREN BACK FROM DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GRANT THE WEEK WANT TO CREATE
PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GREG CHOI IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PATCH WHEN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER LESS FROM SUTTER
FELL PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT NOW FROM PALO ALTO PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN WILL CHAIR THE COMPANY
CLEAN MANY ACTION FUND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ESTHER SISTAN DAVIS CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RICHARD ROSE DAVIS CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SHANE MCLEOD OF SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SUNSHINE IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RATHER THAN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA I PLAYED SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY SAN JOSE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF TODAY OF THE
COURAGE CAMPAIGN AND ITS ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION MEMBERS
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS GREG.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES ON
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY CHAIR
BERMAN MEMBERS -- RYAN RUN CO --
PLASTIC ANY COURT REPORTER
REGISTER VOTERS AND LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CO CHAIR -- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COURSE
IN ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK CENTER
STERN HE IS RIGHT WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING VERY HEALTHY AND ENGAGE
DIALOGUE ON THIS AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL HIS HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL.
I REGRETTABLY WE FIND OURSELVES
OPPOSED TO SB SIX THIRTY SIX WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE AMOUNT OF SPACE THESE EXTRA
WORDS WILL TAKE UP ON THE BALLOT
IN JUST A POINT ON THAT -- WE
HAVE CAN'T WORDS BASED ON
ELECTION CODE SECTION NINE WHICH
SAYS THAT PROPER NOUNS ARE
CONSIDERED ONE WORD SO.
EVERY NAME -- MOST OF A TITLE.
EVEN IF IT'S MADE UP OF MULTIPLE
WORDS WOULD YOU CONSIDER ONE
WORD UNDER THAT SO.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THIRTY WORDS ARE THIRTY SHE
WORDS MIGHT NOT BE THIRTY TWO
WORDS.
AT THE ADDED COST APPROVING
TRANSLATING ADDITIONAL TEXT.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PRINTING MORE
BALLOT CARDS IF THE ADDITIONAL
TAX CREATES A NEED FOR MORE
BALLOT CARDS.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT MAILING
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS BOTH
MAILING TO THE VOTERS.
AND OF COURSE NOW THE POSTAGE
PAID RETURN COSTS OF RECEIVING
BALLOTS BACK FROM VOTERS IF THE
ADDITIONAL TAX CREATES THE NEED
FOR MORE ABOUT CARDS.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THE BILL MIGHT POLITICIZE THE
BALLOT.
HOW VOTERS MIGHT BE CONFUSED AS
TO WHY THIS DOESN'T EXTEND TO
LOCAL MEASURES?
AND THE NEED FOR SPECIFICITY ON
THE NAY ALLEN HOW THE NAME
SHOULD BE PRESENTED ON THE
BALLOT IF THIS WERE TO PASS.
BUT BECAUSE STATE ELECTIONS ARE
NOT REIMBURSABLE ELECTIONS
MANDATES HAVE NOT BEEN FUNDED
FOR SOMETIME.
WE'RE FEARFUL THAT THE CASA
SENATOR ASSISTED WITH SIX AT
THIRTY SIX WILL BE BORNE BY THE
COUNTIES.
HOWEVER WE HAVE AS I SAID BEEN
IN CONVERSATION WITH CENTER
STERN WE THANK HIM FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING OUR CONCERNS AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW WE MIGHT MITIGATE OR
ELIMINATE ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
I THANK YOU IN A PREPARED ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS WITNESS.
HOW COALING BRITAIN WITH
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA -- I'D PASSED OUT A
SHEET WITH OUR OUR CONCERNS OF
MAINLY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WOULD.
INCREASE VOTING LINES AND MAKE
THE TIMES IN THE POLLS LONGER
WHICH WOULD CREATE EVEN MORE
LINE LONG LINES BECAUSE OF THE
LENGTH OF OF THE BALLOT AND
PEOPLE TRYING TO READ ALL THE
DETAILS OF THINGS THEY PROBABLY.
SHOULD HAVE READ BEFORE THEY
CAME IN.
BUT IT'LL BE A CREATE MORE
CONFUSION OF DURING THE ELECTION.
DAY.
AND OF IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN R.
OBSERVERS UP UP.
OBSERVED THAT THE THE ENLARGED
TO CARD BALLOT CREATED A LOT OF
CONFUSION BETWEEN WITH THE POLL
WORKERS AND THE VOTERS.
AND WITH OUR CONSOLIDATE
ELECTIONS THE BALLOTS GET LONGER
EVERY YEAR AND THIS WOULD
COMPOUND THAT PROBLEM SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ABOUT A COLLEAGUES FOR ANY C<c.cyan></c>
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING ON BRING ABOUT A COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
MOTIONS SECONDS.
QUESTION OR COMMENTS MISTER
CALDERON.
YEAH THAT THANK YOU SENATOR --
WE HAD A CONVERSATION EARLIER
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME --
I'M JUST.
I'M STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND THE
NECESSITY FOR THE BILL -- CAN
YOU TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT.
THE PHYSICS FIFTEEN WORDS YES.
SO IS THAT.
DOES THAT REPRESENT I'M A
SUPPORTER AND THIS IS WHY I
THINK YOU SHOULD VOTE FOR THE
BILL OR IS THAT.
HERE WHO ARE WHO WHAT WHAT IS
THAT REPRESENT ONE OF THE
FIFTEEN WERE DROPPED WHAT AM I
GONNA LEARN FROM THIS FIFTEEN
WORDS WHO ARE THOSE SUPPORTERS I
MEAN SAID THAT TO THE WEIGHT
STRUCTURE RIGHT NOW IS IT IT IS
THIS.
WE WE TALKED -- THERE WE
VERIFIES THE SIGNATORIES ON THE
BALLOT STATEMENT.
SO IT.
THE WHOEVER WAS ON A YOU KNOW
THE CAMPAIGN NAY DATE SELECT --
THEIR SIGNATORIES ON THAT BALLOT
STATEMENT AND THEN THAT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY THEN BE
TRANSFERRED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE SO IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT THE FUNDERS PER SE SO
THERE'S A FAIR ARE GOING TO SAY
WELL IF IT'S NOT EXACTLY YOU
KNOW WHO THE TOP THREE FUNDERS
ARTS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE -- THAT
THAT'S NOT CAN BE OBVIOUS BUT
HOPEFULLY THROUGH THE OTHER
DISCLOSE ACT MEASURE YOU'VE GOT
WE SORT OF TAKE CARE THE FUNDING
PEACE BUT YEAH IT'S IT'S WHOEVER
THAT CAMPAIGN SELECTS TO BE --
THE SIGNATORIES ON ON THE BALLOT
STATEMENT SO IF I'M RUNNING PRO
PROPOSITION. SEVEN OR WHATEVER.
I HAVE A LIST OF PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT THAT PROPOSITION NOW
BASICALLY THIS FIFTIES FIFTEEN
WORDS REPRESENT.
WHO AMONG THOSE GROUPS?
RIGHT WE WE WE CHOOSE TO THE
SUPPORTERS ARE YES SO.
I CAN ACTUALLY MIGHT BE HELPFUL
WE HAD A MOCK UP OF WHAT LA IS
WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE HE MIGHT IF
I AS CHAIR TO MINE DISEASE JUST
TAKE.
A VACATION THAT'S GREAT -- THIS
IS SO.
THEY ARE GIVE ME ONE SEC. TO SEE
ALL CAN GET YOUR HEADS AROUND IT
REJECT -- AND REASONABLE MINDS
MAY DIFFER SO.
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
EARLIER IN.
SO YOU'RE LOOKING PICK -- ONE I
DON'T KNOW SIXTY ONE OR SIXTY I
MEAN GOD.
THOSE ARE ALL THE SIGNATORIES.
AND SO YOU YOU'D SORT OF WE WE
MARK THIS UP BASED ON WHAT WE
THINK YOU KNOW.
BASED ON WHO THAT THE THE
SUPPORTERS WERE EXPRESSLY BY
THAT CAMPAIGN AND THIS IS THE
SECOND PAGES HOW WOULD LOOK AT
THE BILL PASSED.
AND THE FIRST PAGES HOW IT
LOOKED TO VOTERS.
LAST CYCLE CURRENTLY SO
CURRENTLY THIS INFORMATION JUST
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
THAT'S IT.
ANYONE PUT ON THE BALLOT THAT'S
IT [inaudible]
OKAY -- YEAH I JUST [inaudible]
I'M IN.
DO I THINK IT'S COULD BE
POTENTIALLY HELPFUL MAY BE I
THINK IT'S NECESSARY I DON'T NOW --
IF IT'S IT WOULD NECESSARILY
SWAY ANYBODY'S VOTES -- ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER I I CAN SIR I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT ADDING ANY MORE
INFORMATION TO AN ALREADY LIKE
THE BALLOT -- AND YOU KNOW I
THINK.
YOU KNOW IT'S GOOD IN THE SENSE
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BUT THAT INFORMATION.
SHOULD BE DIRECTLY ON THE BALLOT
OR SHOULD THAT INFORMATION.
JUST BE IN THE VOTER GUIDE AND
GET THE INFORMATION OUT OF VOTER
GUIDES BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
SHOULD EXPECT THAT INFORMATION.
TO BE AND IF IT'S IMPORTANT
ENOUGH FOR ME. TO KNOW WHO
SUPPORTERS IN THE APPEARANCE
OPPONENTS ARE I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE THE TIME TO GET THAT
INFORMATION ON THE VOTER GUIDE
BECAUSE THAT'S WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
CURRENTLY ALREADY.
EXISTS.
SO I JUST.
I MEAN I DON'T.
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH I
SEVERELY GIPSON IT'S NECESSARY
TO BE SPECIFICALLY IN THAT.
ON THAT BALLOT JUST BECAUSE I
MEAN IT'S AYE AYE AYE I BELIEVE
IN MORE INFORMATION IS BEING
BETTER BUT THEN ALSO LOOK AT
WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA IS DONE THE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
IS TOO MUCH INFORMATION AND YOU
KNOW WHAT I WHAT I WHAT POINT.
AT WHAT POINT YOU KNOW DO WE HAD
TOO MUCH IN THERE'S JUST DO WE
START CREATING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONFUSION.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT STANDARD I
MEAN I'M ARBITRARILY GONNA
CHOOSES.
THE SUPPORTERS OF A SPECIFIC
BALLOT MEASURE HAVE NO
NECESSARILY NOT NECESSARILY HAVE
A PROCESS BY WHICH OF CHOOSING A
SUPPORTERS WERE JUST KIND OF
CHERRY PICKING WHAT SUPPORTERS
WOULD WANT WHICH MIGHT NOT US.
BUT WHICH MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY
ALWAYS BE -- INDICATIVE OR
TRUTHFUL WHEN IT COMES TO WHO
THOSE GROUPS ACTUALLY ARE I MEAN
IF I HAVE.
YOU KNOW THE ALLIANCE FOR
RESPONSIBLE.
BUSINESS OWNERS I COULD USE THEM
AS A SUPPORTER.
BUT THAT COULD BE REPRESENTED BY
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE THAT MAYBE
AREN'T RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES.
I MEAN ARE THERE ANY
DIFFERENTIATION IN THE BILL.
THAT WOULD.
SAY OKAY IF YOU'RE GONNA PUT
THIS GROUP.
THIS GROUP OF SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE.
WHAT ABOUT WHO READY TO SIGN UP
GROUPS YEAH WHO'S REPRESENTATIVE
OF THAT GROUP AND IS THERE ANY
DIFFERENTIATION AND IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO DETERMINE WHO THAT
THAT IT WOULD THEY NOT QUALIFY
BECAUSE THAT GROUP IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF A BUNCH OF
OTHER DIFFERENT?
RIGHT OPPONENTS ARE SUPPORTED
THE BILL IS NOT DOESN'T TRY TO
GET INTO THE NITTY GRITTY OF
THAT AND I I GET THAT CONCERN.
I MEAN.
MY THOUGHT IS -- TIGHT.
IN A CONCISE INFORMATION IS MORE
USEFUL I I MEAN I'M JUST SITTING
HERE READING LIKE PROP SIXTY
THREE FIREARMS AMMUNITION SALES
INITIATIVE STATUTE REQUIRES
BACKGROUND CHECK AND DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AUTHORIZATION. TO
PURCHASE AMMUNITION PRIVATE.
I LIKE I'M ALREADY.
LIKE MY ADD HAS KICKED IN BY
LINE.
THREE I'LL JUST ADMIT IT RIGHT
AND I'M A LEGISLATOR BUT I THEN
YOU START READING THROUGH THE
FISCAL IMPACT AND YOU HOPE YOU
HOPE THAT THAT'S THAT TELLS THE
WHOLE STORY.
WHETHER THAT NEXT LINE YOU DROP
DOWN TO SUPPORTING SAY
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
FEINSTEIN.
LAWCENTER TO PROTECT YOU KNOW SO
AND THEN COMPARE THAT TO
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION PEACE
OFFICERS LIKE.
ARE THOSE USEFUL SIGNALS IN THAT
CASE I SAY YES BUT YOU KNOW
THERE THERE IS PROBABLY A
SCENARIO WHERE YOU COULD HAVE A
YOU KNOW -- CALIFORNIANS FOR
PUPPIES SUPPORT THIS YOU KNOW
THE EVIL ALEC RUNNING A
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS THEY ARE
NINE ARE A AND WHATEVER ELSE
THERE ARE THE LINE THERE YOU
HAVE IT SO -- I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT THERE ARE ALREADY SOME
LEGAL PARAMETERS IN PLACE FOR
SIGNATORIES OF A BALLOT SO YOU
YOU CAN'T.
YOU CAN'T BE A FALSE
ORGANIZATION I MEAN IT IT HAS TO
ACTUALLY BE BUT AS WE KNOW --
YOU CAN SET UP FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE YOU SEE FOR SO IT'S
SOMETHING ACTUALLY I'M OPEN.
TO WORKING ON REFINING I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU.
YOU SORT OF CUT THAT LINE -- BUT
YEAH I'M I'M OPEN TO SOME
REFINEMENT THERE I I GUESS MY
THOUGHT IS WHOEVER THE
PROPONENTS ARE.
OR THE OPPONENT'S WRENCH I PUT
THEIR BEST FOOT FORWARD.
AND YOU THERE'S GOT TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF TRUST AND THAT
SORT OF THAT HEALTHY OPPOSITION
THAT'S GONNA BEAR ITSELF OUT
THAT.
YOU KNOW EVEN IF OKAY THE SENIOR
ADVOCATES LEAGUE IS IS GOING UP
AGAINST THE CALIFORNIA AGAINST
WASTE LIKE AND YOU DON'T KNOW
ARE YOU MY FOR SENIORS ARE MY
AGAINST WASTE MORE.
AT LEAST THAT HELPS MORE THAN.
REALLY DETAILED LEGALESE SO I'M
WE'RE TRYING TO SORT OF FIND
WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO CUT THROUGH.
EVEN THE WELL CRAFTED NO OFFENSE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
FOLKS WHO SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THINKING THROUGH THESE PUT OUT
STATEMENT.
BUT THERE'D IT'S IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES TO ACTION JUST A
MECHANIC SO THIS OUR BEST SHOT
AT A SIMPLE PROXY BUT I I
TOTALLY RESPECT THE CONCERNED
BECAUSE IT'S A DANGEROUS
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
AND I WORRY ABOUT THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THAT SORT OF NOISE
INFLUENCE TO I JUST I THINK THAT
THIS IS A BETTER WAY TO CUT OUT
THE NOISE SO I I ALSO UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO SIT
IN THAT BALLOT BOX.
FOREVER.
BUT I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY GONNA
MAKE MY DECISION MAKING QUICKER
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO SEE THAT.
ALRIGHT YOU KNOW GAVIN NEWSOM IN
DIANNE FEINSTEIN LIKE.
I I TRUST THEM ON FIREARMS LIKE
THAT MAKES SENSE TO ME IN OKAY
YOU KNOW I HAVE.
YOU KNOW LEADERS THE SHERIFFS
AND I UNDERSTAND BUT IN THIS
CASE SO.
WOULD YOU YOU HAVE TO MAKE YOUR
OWN JUDGMENT CALL WHETHER YOU
THINK THAT KIND OF PROXY.
DISCUSSION IS HEALTHY OR IF IF
WE ACTUALLY SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING VOTERS TO GO READ
THE VACANT SO THE SENATE ON I
APPRECIATE I MEAN I I JUST FUNNY.
FOR ME MY APPROACH IS I I I TEND
TO BE PRETTY LINEAR WHEN IT
COMES MY POLICY IN THEIR
CREATIVE WHEN IT COMES MY
POLITICS AND YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
JUST WHEN IT COMES TO VALIDATE
JUST.
I LIKE OKAY HERE'S THE
INFORMATION HAS THE CHOICE THAT
I NEED TO MAKE AND THEN HERE'S
THE OTHER OTHER PIECE IN A
BOOKLET.
LET THE HAS ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT I NEED IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS ON HERE SO THAT I'M
NOT CREATING ANY CONFUSION ON
THIS PIECE.
THAT WAY IT'S ALL SEPARATE IT'S
NOT IT'S JUST.
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST A LOT.
EXIST ALREADY THERE GOT NO
OBJECTION L. AS JUST THERE'S
JUST A LOT SO -- YEAH I MEAN I I
CAN APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO A MAYBE THIS IS THE WAY TO DO
IT MAYBE IT'S IT'S NOT -- I DO
HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT THE FRONT
GROUPS AND AND WHETHER OR NOT
THOSE THEY WOULD QUALIFY AS A AS
A LEGITIMATE YEAH.
ENTITY TO BE IN SUPPORT ON
OPPOSITION OF A SPECIFIC BALLOT
MEASURE MEANING.
IT'S A MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO
CRAFT SOMETHING THERE WHERE
THERE'S A THRESHOLD THAT YOU
HAVE TO MEET OF A MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION A CERTAIN KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
COULD QUALIFY.
I DON'T LOOK AT THEM NO I
APPRECIATE THAT EMILY OFF TODAY --
BUT IF.
COMES BACK TO FOR SOME DIFFERENT
CHANGES OKAY -- HAPPY HAVE
CONVERSATIONS IN A CONVERSATION
THEY AFFECT THEM IS GONNA
DISMISS -- THEY GIVE US CHAIR --
SENATOR RIGHT.
BECAUSE OF MY DEEP RESPECT FOR
YOU -- START OFF NEUTRAL ON THIS --
TODAY -- AND BUT I BECAUSE WHAT
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED
THIS -- INTEL I SAW THIS -- AND
AND AND GROWING IT DIDN'T ALWAYS.
THE FEINSTEIN IN A NEW SAID THEN
YEAH AND THEN YOU STARTED WITH
THE WRONG YOU STARTED TALKING SO
I'M ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS IS THE LOS.
THAT NOTHING GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY AND LET ME TELL YOU
WHY OKAY -- I THINK IT WITH OUR
STATE MEASURES.
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT --
THAT THE ELECTORATE READ THEM.
STUDY THEM AND THEN VOTE ON
THEIR CONSCIENCE -- BECAUSE WE
ARE INUNDATED WITH INFORMATION.
SOME OF US -- AND TO BE FAIR --
SOME OF US IN THIS HOUSE GET
VERY LAZY -- IN IN IN THE WAY
THAT WE WE VOTE -- AS YOU KNOW --
WE HAVE HERE IN THIS BUILDING --
WITH OUR ANALYSIS SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION.
AND OFTEN TIMES -- WE HAVE -- IF
HIS WE HAVE HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF BILLS THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT AND WE DON'T HAVE
TIME TO TO GO DIG INTO THEM --
AND OFTENTIMES WILL GO THE ALL
MY FRIENDS ARE SUPPORTIVE I MUST
BE SUPPORT OF MY OPPONENTS --
OUR OUR SUPPORT IF I'M GONNA
OPPOSE RIGHT WITH THIS IS WHAT
WE WE WE DO NOT EVEN HERE WHEN
AND WHERE YOU WE GET PAID TO DO
THIS BECAUSE WE WERE IN A DAY
WITH TIME.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE EVEN LOCAL
MEASURES IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR ELECTED TO GO AND
DIG AND FIND OUT AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS THEY CAN.
THE BILL TO MAKE A DECISION AND
OFTEN TIMES -- IF YOU GO AND
LOOK AND JUST GO WELL MY MY THE
PEOPLE THAT I'VE SUPPORTED ARE
SUPPORTING US WITHOUT ACTUALLY
DIGGING INTO IT.
NINE I CAN THINK OF A AND A
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE THAT I WAS --
AND AUTHOR OF HERE THEY GOT ON
THE BALLOT IN NAM AND THE
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN PARTY
OPPOSED IT AND MADE ABSOLUTELY
ZERO SENSE TO ME -- AND IF.
IF IF THIS HAD GONE STATEWIDE IT
WOULD HAVE GONE ON WERE MOST
REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED
BUT SOME IN THE PARTY DECIDED
THEY WANTED -- TO TO TO TO GET
BACK AT ME AND SO THEY SAID NO
WE'RE GOING TO OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE WITHOUT THE ELECTORATE
WITHOUT REPUBLICANS LOOKING AT
SING YOU KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT.
SO I THINK BY LISTING NAMES HERE
ACTUALLY WILL SKEW -- WHAT THE
ACTUAL INITIATIVE WHAT THE THE
LEGISLATION PROPOSED MEASURE IS
GOING TO DO? FOR THAT REASON --
AS CHAIR AND I'M TO TO MY OF MY
FRIEND -- I'M NOT GONNA BE
OPPOSING TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OR MOTIONS OR SECONDS.
I'M ON A MAKE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
ANY SECONDS.
SO WHAT WE WILL KEEP THE THAT --
CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE A SECOND
WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN -- FOR FOLKS
WEREN'T HERE YET -- TO POSSIBLY
MAKE THAT SECOND BREAK THANK YOU
YEAH IF I CLOSE DOUBLY I
APOLOGIZE AND ONE OF THESE
CLOTHES NO I ONLY TAKE ONE MORE
SHOT T MISTER CHAIR AND LEASE
TREADER DO YOU. FOR THE FOR THE
RECORD OF TO TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM [inaudible]
HOME DESERT.
THE ELECTRIC DID TAKE A LOOK AT
THE INITIATIVE IN A QUITE LIKE
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY MAY NOT
HAVE BUT ON THE WHOLE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY AGREED WITH YOU -- THE
BILL IS NOT ABOUT.
HOW WE WISH IT WAS IN DEMOCRACY?
IT'S HOW IT IS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING TO VOTE
ON AND IT'S A IT'S A THE TOUGH
CONCESSION TO MAKE.
THAT.
WE NEED SHORT CUTS -- BUT TO TRY
TO FIND AUTHENTIC MEANINGFUL.
WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO GET TIGHT --
TRUST WORTHY INFORMATION IS
EVERYTHING SO RELYING ON THE
ADVERTISING WORLD OR TELEVISION
OR SOCIAL MEDIA TO ME IS
DANGEROUS.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A TRUST
WORTHY SAFE AND USEFUL PROXY TO
ACTUALLY MAKE DECISIONS.
I UNDERSTAND THE THE CONCERNS
BUT WE'RE GONNA KEEP CHIPPING
AWAY AT THIS SO I HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO CONVINCE YOU ALL GOING
FORWARD THAT THIS MAKES SENSE
AND I I REALLY DON'T WANT TO ADD
CONFUSION OF THAT BALLOT.
IN REGARDS WHERE THIS LANDS -- I
THINK WE CAN ON THAT SECTION
NINE ISSUE CAN DEAL WITH IT.
ON THE ORGANIZATIONAL THRESHOLD
THEY BEGIN DEAL WITH THAT SO I
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION YOUR TIME AND I'LL
STOP TALKING -- OR MAYBE RIGHT
IF I TALK MORE THE MORE I TALK
ME WILL COME ALL THE WAY AROUND
I MEAN.
THANK YOU YES DR THANK YOU
CENTER AND AND I'VE I'VE BEEN
CORRECTED BY MY MY CHIEF
CONSULTANT -- THAT WAS SO WANTED
TO DISPENSE WITH THE MOTION.
DURING WHILE WHILE ITEM IS OPEN --
BUT THEN THE OTHER MEMBERS AND
STILL MAKE MOTIONS IN SECONDS AS
MORE PEOPLE GET HERE ASSISTANCE
OR IS CURRENTLY NOT A SECOND THE
MOTION FAILS BUT THEY'RE STILL
THE OPPORTUNITY INTO THE HEARING
ENDS. FOR A MOTION AND A SECOND
TO BE MADE ON THE ITEM AND TO BE
TAKEN THAT.
VERY WELL CREATE THE THE THE
LONELY MOTION AND I WOULD ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION OF IT DOES
NOT MAKE THROUGH ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING ON WE NEED
SENATORS WE NEED AUTHORS.
WE CENTER ALLEN OR CENTER
MCGUIRE.
OKAY LOOK AT THE NO THAT I
REMEMBER -- SO -- FOR CLOSE
CLOSE INTIMATE.
CLOSE IN TEN MINUTES AND INITIAL.
IF YOU'RE NOT AT A COMPOUND
COMMITTEE YEAH HE'S GOT TO COME
HERE BUT IF YOU ANNOUNCED THAT
YOU'RE CLINTON WITH ALL.
YEAH SO WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
STAY IT WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
HEARING OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES --
FOR ABSENT AUTHORS TO COME AND
PRESENT THEIR BILLS I KNOW THAT
EVERYBODY IS VERY BUSY INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE -- AND
SO UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE HAS
A LOT GOING ON TODAY BEFORE THEY
TRY TO GET HOME FOR THE RECESS --
BUT WE NEED TO RUN A COMMITTEE
HEARING SO AUTHORS OF TEN
MINUTES.
AND WHAT YA YES ABSOLUTELY
DURING THE BREAK LET SEVERAL
WAITING FOR AUTHORSTHAT'S ADD
ON TO ANY MISS VOTES.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
OPEN THE THIRD CALL THE ROLL ON
ITEM TWO SB SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR LEYVA -- THE CURRENT IT
IT HAS.
PAST THAT -- LOW.
LABOR CENTER LIKE THIS BILL.
LOW ON MY MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ITEM FOUR SB.
TWO SIX OUT THERE EXCUSE ME ARM
YOU'VE ALREADY VOTED ON THAT
[inaudible]
ONE I'M SORRY.
ITEM FOR SB TWO SIX EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER -- GALLAGHER
MAYES.
MAYES NOW.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER GALLAGHER.
LOW VERY LOW NOT VOTING.
ITEM SIX SB THREE FIVE NINE BY
MORE LOCK LOW.
NUMBER LOW NOT VOTING MULLIN.
ITEM NINE SB SIX NINE SIX BY --
BURKE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I I DON'T.
WITH REGARD TO THE AL.
ALAM CAR
WHY ARE ALWAYS A
PLEASURE AND AN HONOR SIR.
NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING SENATE
MCGUIRE ALWAYS A PLEASURE AND AN
HONOR.
I BELIEVE WE CAN PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB.
FIVE TWENTY THREE IT'S GOING ON
MISTER CHAIR GOOD TO SEE YOU I
AM -- I'M VERY APOLOGETIC.
IN A IT IS VERY OBVIOUS THAT I
NEED TO RUN MORE.
GOING UP THE STAIRS.
SO WE GET YOU SOME WATER HEY
THERE YOU GO HI TING WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA BE
VERY BRIEF -- AS WILL THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF OUR TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU. TO MISS
MOCK -- WHO IS WITH THE SECTOR
STATES OFFICE FOR ALL OF HER
WORK AS WELL THE SECTOR STATE?
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
LONG STORY SHORT?
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THIS SECOND
VOTER EMPOWERMENT BILL -- E. AND
ITS FOCUS ON THOSE BALLOTS TO DO
NOT HAVE A SIGNATURE.
IN THE GOAL SAY THEY'RE OVER
HALF OF HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE -- VOTE
BY MAIL NOW.
THERE ARE FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BALLOTS THAT WERE REJECTED IN
NOVEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I DID NOT
HAVE THAT MRS SIGNATURE THERE
SIMPLY THROWN OUT.
THIS IS STOP WHICH IS THE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW VOTER TO HAVE
THEIR VOTE COUNT.
IF THERE IS IN THIS IS SIGNATURE
IS A LINES.
WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR THE SECTOR STATE
FOCUSING ON MISMATCH SIGNATURES
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND I WANT TO TAKE HIM
TO SAY MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO YOU.
AND YOUR STAFF YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THINGS THAT ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF NAY MARK
ON BEHALF OF A SECRETARY OF
EXPEDIA. FOR THE REASONS STATED
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERE ARE ROSE THE RIVER IS A
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUILDS
COMMONSENSE BRINGS THE TWO
THINGS INTO ALIGNMENT
[inaudible] THREE SHORT.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE IS IN SUPPORT MY
ANGER I'M A SILLY OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU --
CARES WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BOB LAYING ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF HARDY GEAR ADVOCATE.
KERA HOW.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT ROC OVER THE CALIFORNIA
SITUATIONS OF COURSE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS -- WERE TWEENER REALLY
WERE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED THAT WE
LOVE THE CURE PERIOD -- BUT WE
ARE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LETTER -- GOING OUT THAT MIGHT
BE AN EIGHT PAGE LETTER -- SO WE
LIKE TO STILL TALK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A RAINY HICKS OF CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAVE YOUR CENTER STERN
.
CALLING BRITAIN ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
ARE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL --
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT IT IT --
MARGINALIZES CHECKS AND BALANCES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THERE'S A
LOGICAL PROCESS OF VOTE COUNTING
IN THAT PROCESS.
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PROCESS AND
ATTEMPTS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED.
AND THE ONES CAST BIOLAGE BY
LEGITIMATE VOTERS ALL IN PERSON
AND VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS MUST BE
PROCESSED.
AND COUNTED AND VOTER HISTORIES
UPDATED PRIOR TO BEGINNING OF
PROCESSING.
A PROVISIONAL BALLOTS WITH THE
WITH THIS PROJECTED EXTENSION
THE PROCESSING OF PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS WOULD INEVITABLY OVERLAP
THE PROCESSING OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS.
EVEN NOW WITH THE CURRENT EIGHT
DAY KERR CURING PROCESS THE
OVERLAP IS OCCURRING.
WHEN ASKED HOW DECISIONS
REGARDING THE BALLOT ACCEPTANCE
ARE MADE ONE REGISTER SIMPLY
REPLIED THAT THEY CAN'T
WHICHEVER BALLOT THEY ENCOUNTER
FIRST?
IN DOING SO ALL CHECKS AND
BALANCES ARE GONE TO THE WIND SO
WE BELIEVE THAT. FIVE TWENTY
THREE JUST EXACERBATES THAT
PROBLEM THROWING LEGITIMATE VOTE
PROCESSING INTO CHAOS AND WHILE
IT'S VITAL TO TAKE ALL
REASONABLE STEPS TO ENSURE THAT
NO LEGITIMATE VOTER IS
DISENFRANCHISED ALL INTENDED IT
CONSEQUENCES MUST BE ANTICIPATED
WAITED.
AND MITIGATED PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING ANY PLAN SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE CREATES JUST
CONNECT.
TOWARD MORE DELETERIOUS THAN THE
PROBLEM IT SEEKS TO SOLVE.
AND WE URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I APOLOGIZE ACTUALLY HERE IN
SUPPORT AFTER I LET HIM KNOW
THAT I'M REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING BACK TO QUESTION OUR
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WITH EMOTION WE HAVE A SECOND.
DON'T SEE A LOT OF HANDS CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO MENTION THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THE
DISCRETION OF A READY FOR
REGISTRAR VOTERS TO BE ADDED.
FOR EXAMPLE MISMATCHING
SIGNATURE TO THE DA TO BE ABLE
TO PROSECUTE YEP SO THAT IS
STILL IN PLACE IN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE -- FOURTEEN
THOUSAND BALLOTS THAT ARE TOSSED.
THEIR REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
AND GREENS AND DECLINED TO STATE
AND POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS ALL
THROUGHOUT.
WHY WOULD WE WANT THOSE VOTES
NOT TO COUNT?
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AGREE 2000% SEND THEIR
AYE -- WE WANTED TO RUN THIS BY
MYSELF BUT YOU IT DID.
SO I'M GLAD YOU DID IT -- BUT IT
IT I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- HAVE A STRONG
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW WELL I MAYES.
MAYES NO.
MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S OUT --
WITH FOUR VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OF AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CENTER SO I BELIEVE THE
SENDER STERN IS GOING TO PINCH
HIT. FOR CENTER ALLEN.
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MùT WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHICH ONE IT IS AND WE HAVE
MOST.
A LITTLE LONGER.
WELL YEAH.
IS AS BE TO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE.
WHICH JERRY WHAT WHICH WHICH
EVERYONE YOU WANT EITHER.
I HAVEN'T BEEN ONE TO REGISTER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
DID YOU WANT TO PLEASE YEAH
THAT'S AYE NUMBER THREE SB TO
WANT TO DO RESTORED TO THE
MOTION SECOND STOPLIGHT.
THEY DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND OKAY SO VERY BRIEFLY ONE
EXCEPT THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS -- THIS
BASICALLY JUST AUTHORIZES
GENERAL LAW CITIES ACCOUNTING
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO UTILIZE THE
SAME FUNCTIONS THAT CHARTER
CITIES ARE CURRENTLY HAVE -- TO
ALLOW THEIR VOTERS TO LOOK AT
MAJORITY WINNING VOTE METHODS
FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS LIKE TOP TWO
PRIMARIES IN.
A RANK CHOICE VOTING WITH ME AB
TEST FIND SUPPORT PAGER ANAND IS
FROM FAIR VOTE CALIFORNIA AND
DOOR ROSE FROM LEGAL WOMEN
VOTERS.
THEY'LL BE MORE ARTICULATE THAN
MYSELF SO I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THE YOU CENTER THE BILL HAS A
MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
I MIGHT ADD.
GOOD ALMOST AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN.
BERMAN AND VERSE -- BUT IN FAVOR
AND THAT'S ON THAT SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR AT SEVERAL CALIFORNIA
SEVERAL CALIFORNIA BELIEVES.
THAT A HEALTHY LONG LASTING
DEMOCRACY RELIES ON EVERY
CITIZEN HAVE A RIGHT TO VOTE THE
CAN TRULY CONTRIBUTE TO
MEANINGFUL REPRESENTATION --
CURRENTLY GENERAL LAW CITIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN ONLY HOLD
PLURALITY WINNER ELECTIONS IN
WHICH THE CANADA WITH MOST MOST
VOTES WINS EVEN IF MAJORITY DID
NOT VOTE FOR THAT CANDIDATE --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN COPPER COMING
COST REPORTED THAT BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND 200014402%
OF WINNING CANDIDATES IN SINGLE
SEAT ELECTIONS WERE ELECTED WITH
LESS THAN A MAJORITY WENT THREE
OR MORE CANDIDATES RAND.
ELECTING CANDIDATES WITHOUT
MAJORITY SUPPORT CAN UNDERMINE
VOTER CONFIDENCE IN ELECTIONS IN
GOVERNMENT.
SEVERAL BELIEVES THAT CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTION TO NOT BE PRECLUDED
FROM ADOPTING BUTTON AT THAT
THAT'LL OPERABLE REPRESENT MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OUTCOMES -- ONLY
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONLY CHARTER
CITIES AND COUNTIES MAY USE RUN
OFF ELECTIONS OF RANK CHOICE
VOTING IN THEIR LOCAL ELECTIONS.
THIS MEANS ROUGHLY 75% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES DO NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO USE THESE
METHODS.
CITIES USING TOP TWO RUN OFFS
INCLUDE TO THE BEST SAN DIEGO --
SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND BERKELEY
SANTANDER USE RANK TWICE VOTING --
IN RECENTLY IT RANKS WITH
READING WITH A ADOPTED STATEWIDE
WOULD GIVE GENERAL LAW CITIES
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THE ABILITY TO ADOPT TOP TWO AND
RANGE WHICH VOTING FOR LOCAL
ELECTIONS THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO ADOPT.
AN ELECTION AT THAT SUITS LOCAL
NEEDS AND LEAD TO A DEMOCRATS
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THAT WORKS
BETTER FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WE URGE IN A BOAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
LEGAL VOTERS A CALIFORNIA DOOR
ROSE IN STRONG SUPPORT I'M GONNA
SKIP ALL OF THE BUT POLICY
ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE.
BUT I DID WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE
OF ONE OF OUR BAY AREA LEAGUES
THAT WHICH ADVOCATED FOR THE
ADOPTION OF RIGHT CHOICE VOTING.
BECAUSE I THINK IT HELPS BRING
SOME OF THIS TO LIFE THE CITY
HAS HAD DISTRICT ELECTIONS FOR
MANY YEARS RIGHT.
DISTRICT ELECTIONS PRIOR TO
ADOPTING WRENCHES VOTING USE A
SYSTEM OF PRIMARY RUN A FOR ALL
CITY ELECTIONS MAYOR CITY
COUNCIL CITY AUDITOR.
THE ELECTIONS WERE CONSOLIDATED
WITH STATE ELECTIONS TO THE
PRIMARY WAS IN EITHER JUNE OR
MARCH OF THE CANDIDATE RECEIVED
A SIMPLE MAJORITY VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY ELECTION.
THEY WERE DECLARED THE WINNER
AND THERE IS NO RUN OFF IN
NOVEMBER.
CANDIDATES WORKED REALLY HARD IN
THOSE PRIMARY ELECTIONS IN ORDER
TO AVOID HAVING TO PAY FOR AND
RUN.
CAMPAIGNS IN TWO ELECTIONS SO
THE RESULT WAS THAT ELECTIONS
WERE OFTEN DECIDED BY A SMALL
VERY ON REPRESENTATIVE PRIMARY
ELECTORATE CANDIDATES WERE
ELECTED IN JUNE.
BUT DIDN'T TAKE OFFICE UNTIL THE
NEXT JANUARY SO HUGE GAP ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS THE CITY CHOSE
TO ADOPT RANGE WAS VOTING WAS TO
ENSURE THAT CITY IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT OFFICIALS.
WOULD BE ELECTED AT THE GENERAL
ELECTION IF THEY WERE GOING TO
HAVE -- PEOPLE ELECTED IN ONE
SINGLE ELECTION THEY WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ELECTION HAD
THE BROADEST REPRESENTATION
POSSIBLE THEY ALSO WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT ELECTIONS WERE
DECIDED BY MAJORITY VOTE.
CITIES ELECTIONS FREQUENTLY OF A
LARGE NUMBER OF CANDIDATES FOR
ANY GIVEN OFFICE EVEN THE EVEN.
UNLESS THERE'S AN INCUMBENT
RUNNING [inaudible]
SO.
USING A SYSTEM IN WHICH THE TOP
VOTE GETTER WINS IN A SINGLE
ELECTION COULD LEAD TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS CHOSEN BY RELATIVELY
FEW SMALL NUMBER OF VOTERS.
RANKED CHOICE VOTING WAS A
SOLUTION TO BOTH THOSE CONCERNS
RIGHT HAVING ELECTIONS DECIDED
OF THE GENERAL ELECTION AND ALSO
ENSURING THAT THOSE ELECTED.
SICK WERE SELECTED BY MAJORITY
VOTE.
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS IS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE INDICATED THAT THEY
DON'T FEEL THE NEED TO VOTE FOR
DEFAULT CANDIDATE WHO CAN WIN
THAT THEY DON'T REALLY WANT OF A
FOUR BUT THEY CAN WIN.
NOT AS THEIR FIRST CHOICE BUT
ANYWAY THEY CAN BOTH THEIR HEART
AS THEIR FIRST CHOICE VOTE.
AND THEN THEY CAN BE MORE
PRAGMATIC WITH SECOND AND THIRD
CHOICES FINALLY.
THE LEAGUE FOUND THAT THERE'S
LESS NEGATIVE CAMPAIGNING IT
HASN'T DISAPPEARED BUT IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR CANDIDATES TO
DISPARAGE OTHERS RUNNING FOR THE
SAME OFFICE WHEN YOU'RE ASKING
FOR SECOND AND THIRD CHOICE
VOTES PLEASE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M WE'RE GETTING BUT I'M GONNA
SHOW HANDS ARE YOU WE DON'T HAVE
TO GET A SHOWING AS WITH SOME
YOUR REASON THEIR HANDS I SEE IS
A BUNCH OF SUPPORT BUT TO
SUPPORT.
AWESOME AWESOME AWESOME AWESOME
THANK YOU AND FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY
WANT TO COME TO THE MIKE PLEASE
FEEL FREE.
I'M HERE NOW BUT YEAH THAT
PLEASE THANKS.
POLLY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR ELECTORAL REFORM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I DON'T ON BEHALF OF
FAIR VOTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY EVEN SUPPORT
PROPORTIONAL REPRESENTATION
SINCE THE MID EIGHTIES SO WITH
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALVIN WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EXCEPTIONAL COUNTY GREEN PARTY
N. K. A CALIFORNIA GREEN PARTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANE MCLEOD OF SACRAMENTO OF
REPRESENTING ELECTION EQUALITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'LL ROBERT COPLAND SECOND GREEN
PARTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT A
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
AS YOU KNOW QUESTIONS AS IN --
COMMENTS CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I FAIRS TRAVEL THANK
YOU SIR AS A GOOD BILL I HAVE A
STRONG AYE RECOMMENDATION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST MISTER PASSES AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE LOW AYE
LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS OUT WITH
FIVE VIRTUALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER IF YOU LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO NUMBER ONE SB FORTY SEVEN
YES SIR -- MEMBERS SB FORTY
SEVEN REQUIRES SIGNATURE
GATHERERS TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA VOTERS
WITH THE NAMES OF THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS ADMINISTRATIVE CAMPAIGN
AT THE MOMENT WHEN THE
DISCLOSURE IS CRUCIAL WHEN THAT
PHYSICAL PETITION IS PLACED.
BEFORE THE VOTERS IN ADVERTISING
AND HAVE SOME GREAT SUPPORT HERE
WITH TRENT LANGUAGE CLEAN MONEY
INDOOR ROSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE.
THANK YOU CENTER PLEASE.
BILLS GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND.
BUYING A COUPLE OF THE MONEY
CAMPAIGN PROUD TO SPONSOR WILL
THANK YOU CENTER -- STERN FOR
PRESENTING FOR US.
THIS IS -- STREETS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD EXTENSION THE
DISCLOSE ACT.
REQUIRES THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHEN
POLITICAL ADS ARE ARE BEING PAID
WHO THEY'RE BEING PAID FOR WE
BELIEVE THAT -- PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW WHEN INITIATE SIGNATURE
GATHERERS WHO THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS ARE THAT IT'S JUST AS
IMPORTANT -- WE'VE CRAP THIS TO
BE AS AS AS REASONABLE AS
POSSIBLE -- THE VOTERS JUST HAVE
TO SHOW.
THAT THE CHALLENGES HAVE SHOWN
OFFICIAL TOP FUNDER SHEET THAT
SHOWS THE TOP THREE FUNDERS IT
ONLY HAS TO BE UPDATED -- ONCE --
ONCE A MONTH -- SO THIS WHICH
WILL PROVIDE.
INFORMTION VOTERS A NEED AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
NEXT ONE IS IN SUPPORT DOOR ROSE
LEGAL RIVERS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
I'LL JUST.
I JUST IN WITH MY LAST PARAGRAPH
ACCORDING TO THE PP I SEE IT
MORE THAN 80% OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS OF BOTH PARTIES SUPPORT
INCREASED DISCLOSURE OF
FINANCIAL BACKERS OF INITIATIVES.
IT'S A TIMELY BILL AND WE
RECOMMEND AN EYEFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND WE GOT A SAID
THE MIKE.
THERE IT IS MELISSA ROMERO AT
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED. TO PASS
LONG THE SUPPORT OF COMMON CAUSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KATHY CARRIAGE BENICIA IS FOR
SAFE AND HEALTHY COMMUNITY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SUSAN ARNOUT STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
GARY APPEL MILL VALLEY PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOWARD MATTERS HAVE OAKLAND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU AMY
HILLY WALNUT CREEK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHELLY CAROL SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY VARGAS DAVIS CALIFORNIA
PAT SACKS OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PAT LANG LOS ALTOS HILLS STRONG
SUPPORT YOU.
WHEN AT BUCKMAN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT?
VICKI MILLER OLIVERA.
SAN HAS A STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GRANT HERE WE WANT TO CREATE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROB FAMILY SAN JOSE DITTO THANK
YOU.
DON CURRY MENLO PARK STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND FOR THE
RECORD HENRY STERN HAS BECOME
EVAN LOW WHO IS NOW.
OVER THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN.
PLEASE CONTINUE MIKE LEVINSON
DALY CITY TO WHOEVER'S UP THERE
STRONG THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GERALD MORAN PALO ALTO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
PAGE WHEN OAKLAND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DAVIS MET SAN FRANCISCO STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT HICKS CALIFORNIA GREEN
PARTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SCOTT KELTNER PALO ALTO PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELEN AVAIL OAKLAND STRONG
JEFF HARDY HERE.
ADVOCATE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BARBER WITH THEM AFTER TEN ON
BEHALF OF A INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STAY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GREG SHOW IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT NEFF PALO ALTO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KAREN BACK DANVILLE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATCH THRILLED SACRAMENTO.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND ORGANIZE NGUYEN LEGISLATE.
SACRAMENTO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
ESTHER SYSTEM DAVIS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RICHARD ROSE DAVIS CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY CUTHBERTSON OPEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER HAGEE SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHIU JACKSON BERKELEY PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
LINDA CORNEIL WHOLE MILL VALLEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
OUR PERSICO SAN FRANCISCO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID NEWS WHEN A SUNNYVALE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETEEN OF
PALO ALTO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN THE LATEST FROM DAVIS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHANE MCLEOD SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SOME OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN MAY
ACTION FOR FUND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHRISTOPHER LESS FROM SUN ROOF
HELP PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU --
RUBBER COME FROM THE SECOND A
GREEN PARTY STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WRONG WITHOUT FROM SAN FRANCISCO
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WEBER ON BEHALF PIECE
FOR A PARTY CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HELL TIPPING SAN JOSE POLICE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DUNKERLEY SENATE SAY ME.
TOO THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED TO U. S. P. FORTY SEVEN
I LIKE HOW -- SENATOR I'LL
BECOME SENATOR STERN BECOMES.
SEVEN ONE SAID THAT IT'S A NEW
TRANSITION ON THIS BILL -- BUT
YEAH MEMBERS LISTEN WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO TRANSPARENCY WE LOVE
TRANSPARENCY BUT WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL FOR TWO REASONS NUMBER
ONE WE DO BELIEVE THIS IS GOING
TO PLACE EXPENSIVE BURDENS.
ON PETITIONER GATHERS EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE ONLY UPDATED
UPDATING THE LISTING OF THE TOP
FUNDERS EVERY MONTH -- THERE'S
STILL THE THREAT OF CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR FAILING TO COMPLY
WHICH WILL BE EXPENSIVE AND YOU
STILL NEED TO UPDATE AND REPRINT
THE PETITIONS EVERY MONTH WHICH
WILL ALSO BE EXPENSIVE.
FURTHER WE THINK THE BILL IS A
LITTLE BIT REDUNDANT -- THE
FUNDING OYSTERS ALREADY
AVAILABLE ON THE FCC'S WEBSITE --
AND ALSO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S WEBSITE AND GOVERNOR
BROWN TO VETO A SIMILAR BILL
BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN A. B.
FOUR HUNDRED BY THEN ASSEMBLYMAN
FONG -- AGAIN MAINLY ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THE BILL WAS
REDUNDANT SO MAYBE THE CHAIR OR
SUBSTITUTE AUTHOR CAN SPEAK TO
THAT AND ASK FOR NOVA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES
SEEING NONE -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT GREAT --
THIS BILL WILL HELP WILL HELP
VOTERS MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT REQUIRING THAT VOTERS BE
PROVIDED WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TOP FUNDERS A BALLOT MEASURE
CAMPAIGNS OF THE TIME THAT THEY
ARE ASKED TO SIGN THE PETITION.
I SUPPORTED A SIMILAR PROPOSAL
LAST SESSION I'M HAPPY TO
RECOMMEND SUPPORT ON THIS BILL I
THANK YOU TO THE SPONSORS FOR
BRING IT -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW WELL I MAYES
MULLIN HI MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER.
THE BILL IS OUT -- WITH FIVE
VOTES WILL BE THE ROLE APPS --
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SOARING OVER THE ROLE -- FRAPH
MEMBERS WE WILL ADD ON ITEM TO
SB SEVENTY ONE BY LEYVA MULLIN.
HI MULLIN I ITEM THREE SB TWO
ONE TWO BY ALLEN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
MULLIN.
HI MULLIN I ITEM SIX SB THREE
FIVE NINE BY SENATOR MORE LOCK
MULLIN.
AYE MULLIN AYE.
ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN I
WE ARE WAITING FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON AND WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR
NOT MORE THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES --
UNTIL ABSENT MEMBERS ARE ABLE --
TO GET OUT OF THE COMMITTEES
WHERE THEY'RE PRESENTING AND BE
ABLE TO COMMENT AT ON TO BILLS --
I WANNA KNOW FOR THE FOLKS IN
THE AUDIENCE THAT THE ABSENT
MEMBER THAT WE ARE WAITING ON IS
MISTER GALLAGHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
RECESS FOR ANOTHER UP TO ANOTHER
FIFTEEN MINUTES I WHICH TIME WE
WILL ADJOURN.
THE HEARING -- SO WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE RECESS FOR UP TO
ANOTHER FIFTEEN MINUTES THANKS
SEEING NO FURTHER BUSINESS TO
COME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WE ARE
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
HAPPY FOURTH